[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous retrouvons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct Pierre savati Olivier de Lamarche
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
alors c'est moi qui commence alors
pierre Sabatier j'ai 41 ans je suis
marié à Caroline papa de trois enfants
Augustin Jean et Marie je commence par
l'essentiel
l'autre chose essentielle c'est que je
suis auvergnat et de me rendre j'ai créé
il y a 15 ans un cabinet de prospective
qui s'appelle PrimeView passe en
Auvergne aujourd'hui
de l'étape du jour donc merci en fait
d'y faire référence et je le salue s'il
me regarde mais je crois pas qu'à son
âge en fait à 10 ans en fait il regarde
encore mais bientôt je lui suggéré je
suis auvergnat un élément important et
vous comprendrez pourquoi plus tard et
j'ai créé en fait il y a 15 ans
PrimeView qui est un cabinet de
prospective dans le métier c'est
d'acheter de la donnée la traiter
essayer de poser un diagnostic sur
l'état du monde actuel essayer de
dessiner le monde qui vient et par
ailleurs je suis aussi depuis tout
récemment président d'un organisme de
formation spécialisé dans la gestion de
patrimoine
olivier de la Marche
bonjour Alors moi j'ai plus vieux que
Pierre malheureusement
j'ai j'ai eu d'abord une société de
gestion avant j'étais trader ensuite
j'ai une société de gestion en France et
puis
au vu des difficultés d'avoir une
société en France
je suis parti en Suisse et j'ai quitté
Paris en 2015 je suis parti
m'installer dans une maison de famille
dans le dans le Jura
au milieu des des vaches et des vignes
et
j'ai monté ma société qui est un
familier
qui marche très très bien et qui
et je vais bientôt rejoindre mon
familier fils en Suisse m'installer
définitivement en Suisse voilà parce que
j'ai j'ai tendance à avoir perdu une
partie mais mon optimisme et de mon
espoir en ce qui concerne la société
française alors vous avez on vous a
convié ce soir pour la dernière de la
saison pour faire un petit peu
oui oui pour finir en détente
pour en fait poser notre regard sur tout
ce qui s'est passé cette année entre la
guerre les émeutes en France la
solvabilité de la dette française Bruno
Le Maire et notre aimable président de
la République Emmanuel Macron qui aime
les concerts de Elton John
on commence par qui pierre Sabatier
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
qu'est-ce que tu peux me dire sur
l'optimisme en France comment tu vois
les choses est-ce que on peut avoir un
peu d'optimisme ou est-ce qu'il faut un
petit peu secouer le cerisier pour
essayer de voir s'il y a encore des
fruits pas pourri dans l'arbre
je dirais l'un et l'autre d'une certaine
manière on est obligé d'être optimiste
dans le sens où c'est quoi l'optimisme
si ce n'est de d'être convaincu qu'il y
a toujours une lumière au bout du tunnel
alors il est vrai que le tunnel paraît
long et assez sombre aujourd'hui donc je
pense qu'il faut commencer par le point
de départ ce qui caractérise la société
française et je trouve en particulier en
202 2022 2023 à cette succession
finalement de choc qu'on vit mais on
pourrait même revenir en fait au delà
dire qu'en fait on sent bien que nos
sociétés ont commencé à muter depuis
presque une petite dizaine d'années où
tous les référentiels passés sont en
train de tomber et qu'au final on vit
crise sur crise parce que si vous posez
la question en fait aux populations
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on vit au
quotidien mais on vit une crise une
crise sanitaire mais au préalable il
faut s'en rappeler en fait tout de même
parce que c'est pas crise sociale les
gilets jaunes c'est il n'y a pas si
longtemps on a l'impression que ça se
fait une éternité parce pourquoi on a
l'impression que ça fait une éternité
parce que les crises succèdent aux
crises crises sociales sanitaire Chris
géopolitique écrit géopolitique qui
avait d'ailleurs débuté auparavant
puisque je rappelle qu'au milieu des
années 2010 États-Unis Chine c'était
déjà terminé hier que lydiele passait
pendant les 15 ans qui ont permis en
fait à l'économie mondiale d'exploser et
était déjà remise en question et c'était
pas une question de personnalité il y a
Donald Trump à l'époque tout le monde a
dit c'est Donald Trump qui remet en
question finalement l'ordre du monde
mais regardez le sans successeur Jovan a
strictement rien changé quant aux
tensions qui existent entre la Chine et
les États-Unis et donc en réalité ce
qu'il faut avoir en tête et je trouve
malheureusement 2023 n'est que
l'expression encore plus exacerbée de ce
qu'on connaît depuis presque une dizaine
d'années c'est une succession de crise
alors de crise de tous ordres quelle que
soit les disciplines la question qu'il
faut se poser c'est est-ce que tout ça
elle fait du hasard on sait jamais d'où
vient une crise alors j'ai pas parlé
évidemment de la crise environnementale
mais qui est moins une crise qu'une
forme de prise de conscience et d'un cri
de d'une volonté d'autre chose et je
trouve que ça correspond bien finalement
pour qualifier le monde dans lequel on
vit
en réalité nous avons conçu nos modèles
d'organisation modèle de société société
avec un grand S lire pays mais société
aussi avec un petit test mène nos
entreprises en tant que tel sur la base
en fait de référentiel et de modalités
qui étaient les nôtres dans les années
70 à peu près dire que au regard de ce
que nous étions à l'époque en tant que
population bien nous avons créé des
modèles d'organisation avec des idées
bien préconçues sur le sujet qui était
parfaitement adapté à ce que nous étions
et la réalité du monde aujourd'hui
quelle est-elle c'est qu'en réalité nous
avons progressivement changé vous savez
et donc si je fais ce geste là c'est
pourquoi c'est qu'en fait nous étions
alignés au départ et progressivement en
fait nous changeons et vous savez en
fait tout simplement ce que nous sommes
en avril en train de vivre c'est la
tectonique des plaques c'est ce que
c'est l'arc antillais les antiches je
sais pas si si tu es déjà allé en
Martinique ou là ou dans ces coins là je
crois que oui j'ai dit mal n'est-ce pas
voilà référence je savais que tes
références que c'est une référence que
tu connaissais mais qu'est-ce que c'est
la quantité ces deux plaques qui se
chevauchent et vous savez quand deux
plaques se chevauchent et bien il y a du
frottement parfois en fait ça frotte
tellement qu'il y a un volcan et en fait
c'est ce qu'on veut aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on vit quoi on vit
finalement nos propres changements au
regard de modèle d'organisation qu'on a
conçu depuis 40 ou 50 ans et en fait ces
modèles d'organisation ne sont plus
adaptés à ce que nous sommes et vous
savez malheureusement c'est pas un scoop
mais j'ai bien peur que tant qu'on n'a
pas compris qui c'est la reconstruction
de nos modèles d'organisation qui doit
maintenant être reconstruits sur la base
de ce que nous sommes devenus ça vient
pas d'ailleurs c'est nous nos propres
changements dans le population qu'il
faut comprendre pour reconstruire des
modèles d'organisation qui seront à
nouveau adaptés et c'est à ce prix là
qu'on sortira en réalité des dynamiques
de crise qui se succèdent les unes aux
autres mais vous savez j'adore en fait
cette expression qui n'est pas de moi
qui date de 2000 ans qui creuse un trou
il tombe qui taille une haie le serpent
le mort en d'autres termes nous
récoltons ce que nous semons et un
reliqués nous avons semé depuis
maintenant de décennies finalement des
choses qui aujourd'hui deviennent
inadaptées et qui ne sont plus au goût
du jour et donc c'est ça notre enjeu
principal et j'en terminerai par là pour
dire que pourquoi nous n'y arrivons pas
c'est tout simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un hiatus il y a
une distance qui s'est créée entre ce
que nous sommes devenus dire la
population le quidam moyen quoi la
population de terrain et je vous en
parlerai tout à l'heure parce qu'il se
trouve que j'ai de la société dont je
parlais tout à l'heure que j'ai créé à
15 ans son siège est à Paris mais je vis
dans un village de 400 habitants 450
habitants au fin fond de l'Auvergne dans
une forme de ghetto social et on prendra
le temps d'en parler si vous le
souhaitez tout à l'heure et en réalité
du coup je vis dans deux membres qui
sont posées ce que je ressens presque au
quotidien puisque je fais toujours la
bascule entre l'Auvergne et Paris c'est
qu'une la distance est-elle
qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne se
connaissent pas et quand vous êtes face
aux besoins de reconstruction vous
n'avez pas besoin en fait de bons
gestionnaires le gestionnaire c'est
celui qui a un modèle d'organisation qui
l'utilise et qui sait très bien
l'utiliser pour se développer très bien
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça qu'en forme
nos politiques depuis maintenant des
décennies on forme à des gestionnaires
des gens qui héritent d'un modèle
d'organisation et qui en fait
l'implémente sauf que la réalité nous
n'avons pas besoin aujourd'hui de
gestionnaire ou de développeurs
d'entreprise nous avons besoin de
créateurs d'entreprise et
malheureusement ça repose sur des
qualités qui sont très différentes le
créateur d'entreprise c'est celui qui
connaît parfaitement son client sa zone
de chalandise sont territoire et sur
cette base là qui va pouvoir créer
quelque chose qui sera pleinement adapté
pour répondre aux besoins des gens et on
est dans ce milieu ce milieu qui est
presque létal dans lequel aujourd'hui on
a du mal entre des gens qui pilotent et
qui sont dans l'incapacité quasi totale
au regard de la distance qui s'est créée
de comprendre la véritable les
véritables changements de nos
populations à la fois en termes de
besoins mais aussi en termes de désir et
ça il faut pas le nier et leur capacité
à pouvoir répondre et tant qu'on en
sortira pas à savoir tant qu'on n'aura
pas compris que le mot le mot clé ce
n'est pas l'adaptation qu'on entend au
quotidien c'est la reconstruction
non j'ai presque envie de dire c'est le
mot c'est reconstruction reconstruction
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
faisant fit du passé sans le juger on
n'est pas en train de dire que le modèle
d'avant n'était pas bon c'est pas le
sujet il faut jamais juger le passé il
était adapté à ce que nous étions dans
le passé nous avons changé nous avons
besoin d'autre chose et sur cette base
là il faut vraiment intellectuellement
et l'agent enfin au-delà de ça vous avez
compris que je suis un homme de terrain
de territoire mais aussi je suis
entrepreneur depuis maintenant un
certain nombre de décennies et la
réalité c'est ça c'est d'être dans une
posture en fait de reconstruction de
construction c'est comme si vous aviez
une feuille blanche il faut avoir
beaucoup d'humilité par rapport à ça
écoutez son client en l'occurrence
lorsqu'on parle de la société avec un
grand S sans client c'est le citoyen le
comprendre parfaitement pour savoir
créer une société avec des bons
référentiels qui vont finir par répondre
à leurs besoins et aujourd'hui
finalement 2023 c'est l'exacerbation
finalement de notre incapacité à
comprendre que nous ne sommes pas et
l'enjeu du jour n'est pas l'adaptation
c'est la reconstruction
olivier de la Marche positif négatif
prospectif la reconstruction
quel est votre constat quel est ton
constat sur cette année qu'on vient de
passer
à mon constat d'abord c'est que c'est
quelque chose que
j'avais
annoncé dans les
dans les différentes choses que j'écris
et non seulement dans les différentes
choses que j'écris mais dans les dans
les différentes interviews que j'ai fait
précédemment donc
il se trouve que je suis pas surpris et
je suis pas surpris parce que
je pense que le problème c'est surtout
une une manque un manque totale de
volonté de la part de nos dirigeants
pourquoi tout simplement parce que
aujourd'hui on est dans une société qui
est tellement corrompu
tellement
dirigé par des gens qui sont totalement
incompétents au poste qu'ils occupent
que
ils n'ont plus le choix c'est-à-dire que
ils sont obligés de gérer par des crises
et c'est pas des crises qui arrivent
comme ça
on sait comment
c'est des crises qui sont pour la
plupart
voulu et déclencher aujourd'hui je parle
pas je parle pas de la crise sanitaire
évidemment mais je te parle d'autre
chose c'est à dire les crises qu'on a
aujourd'hui
la guerre avec avec l'Ukraine on voit
très bien c'est pas voulu mais si on
voit très bien qui pousse
ils font tout ce qu'ils peuvent pas pour
arrêter la guerre ils font tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour la continuer et
pourquoi non mais c'est pas une
interprétation tu n'en vois pas des
armes pour arrêter une guerre pour
arrêter d'une guerre tu te tu te mets
autour d'une table et tu discutes là on
a rien fait depuis le début pour pour
s'arrêter et pour discuter donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que en fait on en
profite on a envoyé manuel Macron
[Musique]
les Chinois et pourquoi mais tout
simplement parce que je pense que le la
guerre est quand même la guerre que ce
soit une guerre civile donc une guerre
en interne ou une guerre à l'extérieur
et le meilleur moyen de faire
disparaître d'effacer
toute leur toute leur erreurs toute
leurs incompétences et surtout toutes
leurs corruption parce que on voit les
choses qui commencent à éclater aux
côtés de du haut au niveau de Biden de
son fils de l'ordinateur des des
transferts de fonds qui a eu en Ukraine
du blanchiment qui a eu en Ukraine etc
tu les as enfin l'ordinateur de Biden
les procès qui commencent à tomber
le tout ça c'est ça commence à tomber
aux États-Unis alors évidemment on en
entend absolument pas parler sur les
chaînes tra personnels françaises mais
ça n'empêche que aux États-Unis il se
passe des choses et c'est absolument pas
couvert c'est absolument pas suivi et
tout ça moi me fait penser à ce que le
le but du jeu c'est un et on le voit
tous les jours avec les lois qui sont
passées le la fin du droit de propriété
on va revenir là-dessus on va y revenir
mais la fin du droit de propriété etc
tout ça sont des choses où on voit
monsieur breton qui nous explique que ça
y est c'est la fin de la liberté sur les
réseaux sociaux et qu'on va pouvoir
exercer une censure totale donc tout ça
ça va dans le même sens c'est-à-dire il
faut
camoufler il faut effacer
toutes les toutes les tous les indices
de corruption et autres qui ont été
faits depuis des années et je pense
malheureusement qu'ils sont capables
d'aller très loin
pour pouvoir en rester au pouvoir
et de continuer leur petites affaires
alors je vais me faire aussi l'avocat du
diable parce que bon Thierry Breton
n'est pas là pour se défendre ou ni même
Emmanuel Macron malgré tous les messages
qu'on a pu lui envoyer sur son téléphone
portable et les réseaux sociaux même si
vous connaissez mes positions là dessus
imaginez-vous que pendant les émeutes au
lieu de se donner rendez-vous à l'Aldi
du coin pour envoyer une voiture bélier
il se soit donné tous rendez-vous à
Paris
peut-être que ça aurait créé des petits
problèmes pour notre capacité à gérer la
logistique le problème de la gestion des
flashs mobilisations des flash mob
peut-être que en réponse à cette
inaction d'État il est nécessaire
de censurer les réseaux sociaux bien sûr
on se félicite
on ne sait plus quel est le fond
mais ça va ça va de pire de de
c'est épouvantable donc et aujourd'hui
on est là on se fait ici on dira c'est
quand même bien les dealers ils sont
décidés
alors deux éléments de réflexion par
rapport à ça c'est pas nouveau utilisé
en fait en gros les différents
excusez-moi si je reprends les termes de
notre président qui dur charismatique
Emmanuel Macron qui aurait pu prévoir
les émeutes alors personne personne
malheureusement en arrivant ici j'ai
oublié en fait ma boule de cristal
encore de la voiture j'aurais pu sinon
peut-être y répondre mais là en
l'occurrence je l'ai pas non mais soyons
sérieux par rapport au sujet
premièrement élément de réflexion par
rapport à ce que disait Olivier sur
finalement l'utilité des conflits
conflits externes ou conflit interne la
réalité en fait c'est depuis toujours à
ça sert le conflit externe ou interne à
masquer les difficultés ou les
difficultés qu'on peut éprouver à
répandre au véritables besoins des
populations c'est une forme de diversion
je ne sais pas si aujourd'hui en fait
c'est ce voilà c'est ce dont il s'agit
mais en réalité historiquement parlant
ça a toujours été le cas toujours quand
les Chinois ont des problèmes et bien
bizarrement les conflits en fait
vis-à-vis de l'externe en fait on
touchant toujours exacerbé c'est depuis
toujours en fait l'usage du conflit
qu'il soit externe en interne permet de
masquer les véritables problématiques en
interne ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point sur la question des
émeutes quand se réjouissent ou pas de
telles résolutions de conflits internes
à travers des prises de parole
finalement de la sphère publique ce qui
me fascine c'est qu'en réalité en fait
on se réjouit de la solution sans jamais
s'interroger sur la cause et le vrai
sujet c'est la cause c'est pas tellement
comment en raisonner mode c'est pourquoi
les matelas et en fait j'en reviens à ma
question initiale excusez-moi mais ça va
être un peu mon fil directeur là de
toute la soirée c'est celui de la notion
de reconstruction pourquoi va se
reconstruire parce qu'en réalité les
fondations sur lesquelles on s'est bâti
depuis les années 70 qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est une idée de base et parfois en
fait les choses paraissent tellement
énormes qu'on se dit c'est pas possible
c'était voulu vous savez faites une
erreur par jour une petite erreur par
jour et regardez en fait ce qui se passe
30 ou 40 ans plus tard c'est énorme et
en fait c'est ce dont il s'agit
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui a dessiné
notre monde au mieux des années 70 une
idée toute simple la puissance découle
de la taille la puissance découle de la
taille
si la puissance découle de la taille
pour exister dans le monde qui vient il
faut être gros tout simplement la seule
perspective qu'on a donné à toutes nos
populations c'est pour exister le monde
qui viennent faut s'être il faut être
gros pas grand c'est pas le mot qui
comptait c'est pas grandir c'est grossir
la conséquence de cela 40 à 50 ans plus
tard qui est assez naturel si vous êtes
persuadé que pour exister un manque qui
viennent faut être gros il faut grossir
il faut grossir entrepreneurialement
parlant ça crée une tension énorme dans
le monde des entreprises qu'est-ce qui
parcourt le monde entrepreneurial depuis
maintenant des décennies la
consolidation c'est quoi les gafam les
gafam c'est notre rust de la fin du 19e
siècle c'est des entreprises qui sont si
grosses qui sont devenus en fait
gigantesques qui sont devenus d'ailleurs
totalement anonymes mais au-delà de ça
surpuissante et presque en concurrent
légitime de l'État je rappelle qu'en
2018 ou 2019 sur scène toi et moi
d'ailleurs on expliquait ce qui allait
se produire sur ce sujet là qui était
simple c'est pas parce qu'on est
meilleur que les autres c'est que en
réalité quand vous avez une entreprise
privé qui devient un concurrent légitime
de l'État ça ne peut pas durer
éternellement les Chinois nous ont très
bien montrer eux directement voilà ils
ont mis en tôle en fait les patrons ils
ont disparu à moi de moi le temps qu'il
fallait pour les faire rentrer dans le
rang chez nous ça mettra évidemment
beaucoup plus de temps comme ça en avait
mis beaucoup à la fin du 19e je rappelle
que les lois antitrust les premières
c'est 1893 pour une première tentative
de découpage en 1904 et un vrai
découpage la Standard all en 1911 donc
ça met toujours du temps mais c'est
automatique quand vous devenez si gros
que vous donnez surpuissant et un
concurrent légitime de l'État et bien
concrètement ça peut pas durer longtemps
parce que les populations expriment en
fait cette dissonance on peut pas avoir
une entreprise privée qui deviennent
concurrente de légitime de l'État ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
pour revenir à la notion d'émeutes la
conséquence de cette idée fixe qui était
dire pour exister à moi qui vient il
faut être gros qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on
a concentré toutes les activités
toujours au même endroit c'est vrai en
France mais c'est vrai partout dans le
monde ce qu'on appelait les métropoles
les mégapoles toujours
il n'y a pas une activité qui s'est
créée dans des territoires qui n'étaient
des territoires des concentrés toujours
plus gros toujours au même endroit
qu’est-ce qui se passe quand vous
concentrez toute l'activité au même
endroit question il se passe quoi mais
il se passe que les gens qui grandissent
finissent par rentrer dans la vie active
et ben pour grandir dans la vie il faut
avoir un travail jusqu'à un certain une
époque il fallait avoir un travail et
ben du coup les gens migrent et donc
vous amenez à avoir des soldes
démographiques des flux de population
qui sont permanence positives dans des
endroits finis on en reviendra peut-être
à un moment donné à la question
environnementale qu'un sujet central
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe quand vous
amenez tout le temps en fait plus de
monde dans un endroit fini
déjà emprunt environnemental délétères
question ces grandes villes dont on
parle ces grandes métropoles Lyon Paris
autre pourquoi elles sont là parce que
pendant des décennies où on n'avait pas
la mécanisation et bien elles étaient là
où il y avait déjà plus de monde mais
autour de ces villes là il y avait quoi
des terres arabes parce qu'il avait
fallait bien en fait que les gens les
populations mangent en amenant en fait
la concentration de l'activité toujours
au même endroit et un flux de personnes
permanent en éloignant les gens pour
qu'ils se loge vous faites quoi
d'appréhension faite de terrain donc
artificialisation des sols ça me fait
marrer d'une certaine manière
aujourd'hui on fait des lois pour mais
ça fait 50 ans en réalité qu'on a
organisé l'artificialisation
l'artificialisation des sols les plus
arabes en fait d'un autre territoire ça
c'est le premier point deuxième point
vous éloignez donc pour aller bosser il
faut soit prendre sa bagnole je suis
désolé mais il faut prendre sa bagnole
donc sa voiture pardon embouteillage
emprunt environnementale délétère mais
au-delà même de ces conseils d'argent ou
infrastructures publiques vous allez
dire oui mais il y a des RER vous prenez
le RER oui oui de temps en temps pas
souvent oui non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que le temps et la fatigue générée
et colossale mais le pire du pire et
c'est là où il faut avoir en tête cela
c'est pour ça qu'il faut le toucher du
doigt le pire du pire c'est qu'en fait
ces deux à trois heures par jour que
vous perdez il se passe quoi le soir
quand vous rentrez chez vous qu'est-ce
qu'on fait 40 chez vous qu'on a perdu 2
à 3h en fait de fatigue de stress etc il
se passe quoi mais il se passe que vous
restez chez vous dans votre canapé parce
que vous avez plus d'énergie et en fait
le sujet principal et la conséquence de
cela elle est simple c'est qu'en fait
les gens là où vivent les gens ça
devient progressivement en fait des
lieux qui sont des lieux morts parce que
je rappelle qu'il y a un pilier qu'il
faut pas oublier dans notre population
pourquoi notre pays tient pourquoi notre
pays est résilient alors qu'Olivier
c'est vrai ce que tu dis franchement on
aurait dû s'effondrer déjà mais pourquoi
parce qu'en France plus qu'ailleurs on a
un pilier qui est souvent en fait est
oublié ça s'appelle le pilier associatif
innovation radicale majeure en termes
politiques en 1901 on a doté en fait nos
population quel que soit la personne
dans notre territoire d'une coquille qui
permet de porter son initiative outre
quelques enfin quel que soit les
considérations capitalistiques associées
donc ça c'est formidable et notre ça
c'est vraiment véritablement des piliers
à nos sociétés mais il se passe quoi
aujourd'hui quand vous faites perdre 2 à
3 heures par jour en fait de temps
d'énergie de force en fait aux
populations qui rentrent chez elle qui
ne veulent plus sortir de quoi manque le
plus nous associations ce pilier central
le manque d'argent dans le manque pas
d'argent elle manque de gens aujourd'hui
et la réalité c'est qu'en fait les gens
restent chez soi et progressivement vous
rentrez ce qu'on appelle la cité dortoir
et en fait une vie qui est une vie de
plus en plus autocentrée c'est pas que
les gens deviennent plus individualistes
c'est qu'on a créé les conditions pour
qu'il le devienne et c'est vraiment un
facteur majeur tout ça pour dire qu'à la
fin tout ça pose les jalons d'une
société devenu anonyme
anonyme dans lequel les gens ne se
connaissent plus ou ne se reconnaissent
plus et vous savez la caractéristique
d'une société anonyme c'est quand on se
connaît plus on ne se reconnaît plus et
bien le fameux sur moi de Freud vous
savez un être humain c'est quoi c'est un
ça un réservoir des pulsions plaisir en
surmoi c'est les lois historiques dont
on hérite qui font faire que d'une
certaine manière c'est le bien et le mal
ce qui va faire que non je ne vais pas
exprimer en fait tout toutes mes
pulsions et donc je vais me comporter
correctement dans la communauté et le
moi c'est quoi c'est vous et moi nous
vous et moi ce soir en fait et c'est mon
rapport au monde extérieur tout ça pour
dire que lorsque nous devenons des
sociétés anonymes petitesse mais aussi
petit grand S société anonyme est
concrètement nous devons nous ne pouvons
plus en fait mobiliser en fait le surmoi
dans nos populations parce que les gens
ne se connaissent plus ils ne se
reconnaissent plus donc d'une certaine
manière si on ne se connaît pas peu
importe l'acte que je fais même s'ils
soient vicieux je n'en subirai pas en
fait les conséquences et c'est ça en
fait majeur par construction une société
anonyme devient une société violente
parce que nous ne pouvons plus actionner
le levier du surmoi de l'autocensure
celle des gens pas celles qu'on leur
impose celle des gens celles qu'on
hérite celle qui suit en fait de
l'éducation et par construction ça
devient une société violente et comment
vous faites pour apaiser et après
j'arrête mon tunnel promis la loi et la
répression c'est comme le dopage et le
contrôle handy dopage mais si vous
comprenez pas que le problème originel
vient du fait que cette idée qui s'est
disséminée au fil du temps depuis le
milieu des années 70 qui était de dire
que la puissance de découle de la taille
donc pour exister dans le monde qui
vient il faut être gros et délétère et
mortels mortels pour nos sociétés avec
un petit test mais aussi avec un grand S
et bien concrètement vous passez à côté
des choses et donc peu importe la
résolution des émeutes les émeutes
reviendront parce que par construction
la société telle qu'elle est dessinée
devient société violente olivier
Delamarche quand on voit notre leader
charismatique Emmanuel Macron quand on
voit certains de nos intellectuels
prêchés sur la censure des réseaux
sociaux
le fait qu'on puisse déconnecter les
appels à la révolte
historiquement parlant ça fait résonner
quoi en vous est-ce que vous voyez une
angoisse du pouvoir est-ce qu'il
s'attendent vu les facteurs économiques
qui sont déployés devant nous les rails
que notre économie nous propose entre la
récession de la zone euro la récession
des États-Unis
l'inflation l'inflation qui va peut-être
atteindre un plateau qui va peut-être
descendre
quand vous voyez tout ça ça vous fait
résonner vous tirez quelle analyse tu en
tire quelle analyse est-ce que Bruno Le
Maire est suffisamment agile est-ce que
non mais tu as tu as une fuite en avant
prévisible c'est à dire que plus
tu as quand même une depuis un petit
moment tu as quand même une prise de
conscience de beaucoup de gens qui
commencent à comprendre que ça va pas
alors certains ont pas encore tout
compris mais ils comprennent que
qu'on se fige de leur deux que quand on
entend les déclarations de Bruno Le
Maire c'est c'est de plus en plus
lunaire et donc ils comprennent ça et
ils comprennent ça et et aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir continuer tout simplement
pour pouvoir
subsister pour pouvoir
échapper
aux raccourcissement
de la guillotine
mais si non mais si tu veux le les gens
aujourd'hui les politiques ils ont peur
ils ont peur parce qu'ils voient ils
voient les gens se réveiller et comme
ils voient les gens se réveiller
qu'est-ce qu'ils font tu as une fuite en
avant sur sur un régime qui est de plus
en plus dictatoriale c'est une évidence
mais ça on le voit le régime qui se qui
se tend qui se situe parce que il y a
pas d'autre réponse puisqu'il a pas de
réponse intelligente puisque de toute
façon en plus quand tu parles de la de
quand c'est pas la même chose quand tu
parles de États-Unis mais quand tu
parles de la France quel pouvoir on a
quel pouvoir on les politiques rien
c'est madame vanderleyen qui qui dirige
l'Europe c'est pas c'est pas monsieur
Macron donc à partir de ce moment là
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'il fasse la
seule chose qui qui peuvent faire pour
essayer de subsister
c'est durcir ou d'agiter les bras
ils agissent les bras aussi mais il
durcit surtout donc c'est on voit bien
que c'est des régimes qui ne tiennent
que sur la communication parce qu'ils
ont pas autre chose en fait ils n'ont
rien d'autre ils n'ont pas d'acte
possible puisque toutes les décisions
sont prises au niveau de l'Europe on n'a
pas récupéré de souveraineté du tout
donc on est les laqués de l'Europe et
puis derrière on est les laqués de qui
on est les laqués des Américains or les
Américains qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
est en train en fait de se passer les
Américains voient que ils ont passé on
va dire le point culminant de leur
existence c'est-à-dire que ils sont en
train de voir que les le la monnaie leur
échappe le le aujourd'hui les Chinois
déposent beaucoup plus de brevets que
les Américains donc
technologiquement c'est plus ça donc le
leadership américain est en train de se
casser la figure qu'est-ce qui se passe
il y a une réaction de la part des
Américains
de peur de réaction de de Pearl de
perdre leur leadership et qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils font ce qu'ils savent
faire le mieux depuis longtemps c'est à
dire qu'ils font la guerre donc
ils nous ont merci
à Monsieur Macron de cette laisser faire
innozon enfoncé ils nous ont ils ont
détruit l'Europe avec avec les sanctions
et les contre sanctions et Monsieur le
Maire qui agitait ses petits bras
ces Poutine qui a envoyé qui a passé la
frontière c'est pas l'inverse oui c'est
Poutine qui avait passé la frontière on
repart de 2014 on parle de de mesdam on
parle de tout ça non Budapest donc si tu
veux le le
tout ça est orchestré par les États-Unis
depuis très longtemps pourquoi personne
ne le dit chez nous parce que personne
à le dire on est beaucoup à le dire la
seule chose c'est que évidemment
personne n'a envie de l'entendre parce
que
non tout simplement parce que c'est
c'est une carrière non c'est l'histoire
qui est qui est acceptée qui est
enfin rabâché en permanence dans les
dans les médias etc et donc on a on a
les États-Unis qui depuis un bon moment
n'ont qu'une obsession c'est de c'est
d'éliminer en fait un concurrent et le
concurrent c'est l'Europe et pourquoi
parce que tu as l'euro qui qui était un
un
refuge or aujourd'hui si tu si tu veux
essayer de malgré le mouvement que tu
vois chez les briques c'est qui était
annoncé en 2017 ils avaient déjà
commencé on avait on l'avait écrit on
l'avait on en avait parlé on avait dit
ce qui allait se passer les Chinois et
faisaient une
décès de monnaies convertibles en or et
et basé sur l'or là ils sont en train de
le sortir c'est l'achèvement du
processus qui avait commencé en 2017
maintenant c'est tous les briques qui
essaient de se raccrocher à ce à cette
monnaie les Russes aussi enfin bon on a
on a tout ça c'est préparé depuis
longtemps or qu'est-ce qui se passe bah
on avait on avait au départ Trump qui
avait au moment de 2017 qui avait
commencé à se dire bon là je vais
peut-être mettre un petit coup d'arrêt
souviens-toi il avait à ce moment-là
essayer de supprimer la licence Android
à Huawei
réponse instantanée des Chinois bon les
gars les terres rares les métaux rares
vous en voulez encore comment on
s'arrange bon tout de suite Trump avait
fait deux pas en arrière parce qu'il
avait compris qu'il avait fait une
bêtise ce que n'a pas compris Bruno Le
Maire quand il a quand il sait attaqué à
la Russie et qui s'est retrouvé avec le
principal fournisseur de matière
première mondiale devant lui et que il
les a traités comme si c'était le PIB du
Portugal ce qui était quand même de
petit salut à nos amis portugais quand
même d'une débilité profonde on les
embrasse mais on l'embrasse les
Portugais pas Monsieur le Maire et en
fait
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah il s'est
passé que le plan chinois qui était là
depuis un bon bout de temps pourquoi
aussi parce que les Américains
commençaient à enquiquiner tout le monde
avec leurs histoires de
d'extraterritorialité du dollar et à te
coller 9 milliards de de d'amandes à la
BNP qu'on payait royalement un rubis sur
long parce que ça nous ère enfin bon ils
ont énervé tout le monde au bout d'un
moment les chinois sont dit et les
Russes sont dit il va falloir qu'on
fasse autre chose il va falloir qu'on
construise un système Swift qui soit
une alternative au système américain
donc tout ça c'est ça a été mis en place
maintenant c'est en train de sortir les
Américains semblent qui perdent la main
et comme tout bonne américain qui perd
la main qu'est-ce qui fait il sort son
flingue voilà c'est tout c'est que ça
après si surprenant en réalité ce qui me
sur ce qui moi m'étonne c'est qu'on soit
surpris par cela est-ce que dans la vie
on a déjà vu finalement un leader
d'antan céder la main paisiblement à son
concurrent et son challenger sans je
réagir en fait c'est action et réactions
et c'est en fait l'histoire du monde
depuis presque 30 ans l'histoire
contemporaine c'est quoi c'est
finalement les Américains ont eu un
moment donné intérêt à l'émergence des
Chinois en tant qu’économie en tant
qu'atelier du monde parce que d'une
certaine manière ils ont pu importer de
la déflation et gagner plus de pognon
parce que ça a permis d'augmenter les
taux de marge pour les entreprises mais
15 ans plus tard quand le concurrent et
le challenger de vie devient
potentiellement un concurrent légitime
au leadership international il se passe
quoi il se passe que naturellement ils
vont pas céder le témoin ou passer le
témoin sans réagir mais quand même
est-ce qu'on est surpris quand on
regarde un peu l'histoire
mais même pas l'histoire lointaine la
Chine quand même est-ce qu'on se
rappelle quand même d'où elle vient à la
fin du 19e début 20e la Chine puissance
mondiale depuis depuis des siècles et
des siècles depuis des siècles il s'est
passé quoi il s'est passé que c'était
pas les États-Unis à l'époque le
Royaume-Uni a fait quoi les a poussés en
fait du bord de la falaise avec la
guerre de l'opium un siècle ça a fait
perdre un siècle imaginez-vous quand
même un siècle de oups un siècle perdu
pour les Chinois alors je veux dire
quand je dis cela je dis pas et bien
alors déjà premièrement ne croyez pas
tout de même que le soft power chinois
soit une vraie réalité elle pourrait
être c'est un sujet où j'ai craint
bouquin sur le sujet une dizaine
d'années qui s'appelle la Chine une
bombe à retardement
pour connaître bien le sujet en fait de
l'Intérieur n'imaginant pas le sauf
power car on vous a en faites fait
perdre un siècle un siècle pour le coup
on vous a humilié pendant un siècle
imaginez qu'on va reprendre le
leadership de manière totalement apaisée
est une vue de l'esprit je vous assure
que moi vis-à-vis de l'Europe vis-à-vis
des pays anglo-saxons Royaume-Uni au
premier chef États-Unis en second chef
évidemment les Chinois ont un peu les
crocs ça c'est le premier point donc ne
pas le voir c'est presque une faute là
on n'est pas en train de dîner ensemble
on parle de pilotage pilotage économique
pilage d'un continent comme l'Europe
imaginez
les deux les deux qui sont dans le temps
long exactement comme les Russes ils
sont dans le temps long c'est des gens
qui ont 20 ans devant eux nous on a ou
50 nous on a 5 ans tu vois c'est
l'horizon un géométrique de nos génies
c'est 5 ans et encore alors je sais bien
que aujourd'hui monsieur notre grand
leader voudrait rester 15 ans
charismatique charismatique voudrait ses
15 ans mais ça n'empêche que leur
horizon c'est un horizon très court
terme et en fait on a des joueurs
d'échecs et de Go et en fait on a des
joueurs de bingo
on fait comment pour sauver le pays
on s'ébroue un petit peu parce que la
France a quand même une voix à faire
porter à l'international et on fait
comment pour sauver le pays en fait sur
ce plan d'abord ça c'est le premier
point il faut se donner les moyens
d'être avant d'être entendu donc tout de
même mais juste pour terminer quand même
là-dessus pour bien comprendre ce dont
on parle à un les comprenez quand même
les moteurs chinois les moteurs des
Chinois aujourd'hui alors c'est pas ni
bien ni pas bien c'est la réalité pour
poser en fait comme un médecin pour
poser la bonne prescription et le bon
traitement il faut faire le bon
diagnostic il faut pas rêver un
diagnostic qui n'existe pas donc les
Chinois ont des vrais vélus d'hégémonie
mondiales c'est clairement affirmé avec
une soif et un sentiment de revanche
exacerbé par le siècle qui viennent de
perdre tout de même ça c'est le premier
point deuxièmement imagine imaginez que
les Américains ne fassent rien et
passent le témoin comme ça de manière
paisible là aussi c'est une vue de
l'esprit ils feront tout et j'en reviens
à mon mot important le mot
reconstruction au là aussi on doit
reconstruire parce qu'en fait notre
monde économique économie moderne est né
en 44 avec les accords de wattenwoods ou
finalement les États-Unis ont dessiné le
monde tel qu'il le souhaitait à travers
le plan Marshall et en dollarisant en
fait le monde là aussi on doit le
reconstruire parce qu'on est au bout
fait de système là donc le sujet c'est
qu'on est face à deux concurrents au
niveau mondial qui s'affrontent je vais
un peu dur mais on compte les points ça
fait 20 ans qu'on s'est organisé pour
compter les points on ne compte pas dans
le dispositif et pour compter il faudra
vraiment qu'on se remontait manche de
manière assez sévère
aussi aussi
oui mais parce que si on comptait les
points et qu'on avait qu'un rôle de
d'observateur ce qui n'est pas le temps
on n'a pas un rôle de d'observateur on
est aujourd'hui le très clairement les
États-Unis font la guerre à la Russie
par proxy c'est à dire par nous donc sur
ce plan d'accord sur le point économique
on a quand même un peu joui finalement
tout de même de l'émergence de la Chine
parce que tout comme les américains on a
pu importer en fait de la déflation très
concrètement ça veut dire quoi c'est moi
un peu tordu des économistes
exporter aussi mais aussi mais voilà
l'ordinateur vous avez en fait à
domicile et la machine à laver coûte
beaucoup moins cher que par le passé on
en a joué autant que les Américains sur
ce plan donc on a on en a un peu
bénéficié mais c'est sûr qu'on était
beaucoup moins proactif et on était dans
le sillage pour le coup des Américains
beaucoup plus que dans la proactivité
pour une raison toute simple c'est qu'en
réalité le diagnostic nous voyons le
monde et les Européens et c'est un vrai
problème voit le monde tel qu'ils
aimeraient qu'ils soient au-delà en fait
alors qu'en réalité le monde est une
multiplication de stratégies non
coopérative et on a beau espérer que
l'histoire en fait de l'humanité fasse
que on sort de cette époque là mais
soyons sérieux aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
l'histoire récente si ce n'est la
démonstration encore aujourd'hui que
l'histoire n'est que succession de
stratégies non coopérative donc en gros
on se fait la guerre en fait il n'y a
que les Européens pourquoi que tout le
monde est beau tout le monde est gentil
et que tout va bien se passer parce
qu'on est tous copains parce que quand
on voit les Allemands nous torpiller
notre système nucléaire il y a que des
Français il y a un peu de marche
Olivier on fait comment pour redresser
le pays on fait quoi là
moi si tu veux ce qui m'embête c'est que
aujourd'hui on voudrait redresser le P
le pays avec les gens qui nous ont foutu
dedans
alors c'est pas c'est pas jouable tu
sais comme le disais
les problèmes pour les résoudre c'est
Einstein qui qui avait
dit ça bon et réellement c'est ça c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui tu
pourras
changer les choses
en France avec une équipe qui est
totalement différente puis quand je dis
une équipe réellement des gens
totalement différents
que ce soit
frontes au frontes comme en back-office
c'est-à-dire tous les hauts
fonctionnaires qui sont au final aussi
aussi incompétent et corrompu que les
politiques donc
c'est une accusation grave mais si tu
veux je peux pas imaginer que les gens
fassent ça gratuitement si tu veux quand
tu as des gens qui te coulent te coule
c'est à dire cool notre industrie
vendre notre industrie aux Américains
etc je ne peux pas imaginer que ce soit
fait totalement gratuitement donc je
pense qu'il y a des retours et j'en suis
même persuadé alors évidemment j'ai pas
la preuve parce que ça arrive très très
probablement c'est on se fout de la
gueule des des Africains en disant que
les pays africains sont corrompus etc
nous on le fait probablement mieux
techniquement si tu veux mais je pense
qu'on est aussi pour eux et même
quelques fois plus donc tu ne vas pas me
faire croire qu'on envoie des milliards
et des milliards à l'Ukraine sans qu'il
y a un retour tu ne vas pas me faire
croire qu'on achète des vaccins comme
Madame vanderleyen l'a fait des
milliards de vaccins qui ne servent à
rien qui qui pourrissent lentement et
qui dépasse leur limite de validité sans
qu'il y ait un retour j'y crois pas j'y
crois pas une demi-seconde
il y a du j'ai possédé par le démon
c'est pour ça tu vois le mal partout je
vois pas le mal partout mais tu sais il
y a des choses où on peut être très très
surpris tout de même moi je me souviens
il y a il y a quelques années où tu
apprenais que des politiques qui
n'avaient fait que de la politique
d'accord donc tu sais tu sais à peu près
ce qu'il gagne un député etc il n'avait
fait que de la politique il n'avait pas
il ne venait pas d'une famille
richissime et tout d'un coup il se
payait un hôtel particulier place des
Vosges tu fais comment tu fais comment
tu fais comment comment fais-tu tout
simplement moi je me souviens que en
tant que conférences quand non je me
souviens qu'en tant que trader si tu
veux j'étais censé gagner 10 fois ce qui
gagnait et que je ne pouvais pas
m'acheter un hôtel particulier place des
Vosges donc je m'interroge simplement tu
vois je ne dis rien d'autre je
m'interroge et donc je me dis que
finalement ces gens là
curieusement ils ont ils manifestent
beaucoup leur envie de parvenir à ces à
ces postes là et curieusement quand ils
en sortent ils ont accumulé une une
fortune considérable donc je me dis que
doit bien y avoir de l'argent qui arrive
dans leur poche d'une manière ou d'une
autre et donc cette cette corruption
généralisée fait que je me dis que tu ne
pourras pas changer les choses tu ne
pourras pas revenir à un autre modèle
comme le souhaite pierre mais comme tout
le monde le souhaite on a tous envie que
la France se redevienne une puissance
mondiale etc ce qu'elle n'est plus
aujourd'hui donc on a tous envie de ça
le seul problème c'est que on s'aperçoit
que on
change l'Hollande on a atterri sur
Macron on va changer Macron on va
atterrir sur qui Édouard Philippe c'est
la même chose
tous ces gens là en fait procèdent de la
même façon tous ces gens là en fait
n'ont qu'une idée c'est leur carrière
c'est ton point de vue complètement ils
ont la franche chevillée au corps c'est
pour ça que toutes nos industries
partent à l'étranger c'est parce qu'ils
ont la France chauvio au corps ils s'en
foutent complètement de la France c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que tu vois monsieur
notre grand leader charisme
en plein émeute ce trémousset au concert
d'Elton ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
je je m'en fous de ce que vous pensez je
fais ce que je veux je suis là je suis
un
bon je m'arrête là mais mais
le le aujourd'hui tout ce qui arrive
était prévisible contrairement à ce que
dit notre grand leader tout ce qui
arrive était prévisible que ce soit les
émeutes ou que ce soit les conflits
armés et
et le réchauffement climatique et tout
ce qui arrive
aussi au niveau de l'Afrique où on voit
l'Afrique qui essaie de nous virer et
maintenant on dit ah bah oui mais vous
savez les méchants russes les méchants
chinois mais qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
pendant pendant 5 ans qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait pendant 50 ans on les a empêchés de
se développer on a on a toute la valeur
ajoutée on l'a on l'a
externalisé on l'a capté
et on est allé leur prendre leur matière
première et on a surtout tout fait pour
arroser suffisamment ce qu'il fallait
arroser pour ne pas que le l'Afrique se
sorte de là où elle était donc
évidemment qu'aujourd'hui on est en
train de payer les les conséquences de
ce qu'on a fait mais il y a rien
d'étonnant là-dedans c'est c'est quelque
chose qui était prévisible et qui
aujourd'hui est en train de se dérouler
maintenant si on veut s'en sortir et
bien il y a des choses à faire mais il
faut surtout récupérer notre
souveraineté et virer les équipes qui
sont là aujourd'hui Olivier tu poses une
question à Pierre
pierre comment fait-on pour virer les
équipes actuelles
bonne question en fait ce que point est
Olivier alors quand même un élément de
réflexion les pratiques politiques et
politiques qui sont là mais les
pratiques politiques effectivement
associées à une forme de conflit
d'intérêt directe été et sont un peu
dater dire qu'aujourd'hui je vois très
bien de qui on parle quand
on pointe du doigt place des Vosges etc
c'est des pratiques des années 80 90
autres très clairement aujourd'hui dans
le champ politique les gens
s'enrichissent pas énormément dire que
c'est le premier point mais ça c'est un
élément à limite de détails on s'en fout
un peu la question en fait ce que tu
pointes du doigt c'est les hommes et les
femmes moi je pointe d'abord en fait
pourquoi en fait il faut les changer
c'est pas eux qu'il faut changer c'est
les idées qu'ils ont dans la tête c'est
en fait c'est un problématique d'idées
c'est pas un problématique en fait de
personnes c'est ça qu'il faut dépasser
tout à l'heure j'évoquais j'ai commencé
par ça volontairement quand vous avez
une petite musique déjà 1 vous êtes
premièrement quand vous êtes votre
métier c'est géré c'est pas créé c'est
géré il y a tous votre métier c'est
gouverné donc c'est prévoir mais merci
mais j'ai mis en réalité ça c'est des
mots dans les faits aujourd'hui en forme
des gens pour gérer en fait une
mécanique qui a déjà été inventé par des
prédécesseurs c'est ça le sujet donc
c'est pas autre chose oui et des
communicants par ailleurs parce qu'ils
ont parlé on forme des communicants
c'est-à-dire qu'on forme des gens qui
sont là pour essayer de nous vendre une
un narratif qui est qui n'a rien à voir
avec la réalité mais qui est un narratif
qu'ils doivent donc on est et on est
aujourd'hui et ça c'est ce qui est
encore pire on est aujourd'hui en train
de déconstruire la fameuse Sandrine
Rousseau qui nous parle de
déconstruction des hommes mais
attention on est temps c'est tout ce que
je dis pas plus loin je ne vais pas plus
loin donc
on est en train de déconstruire
déconstruire la société déconstruire le
tout le tout le le
les problèmes qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
l'éducation etc tout ça ça vient de la
même chose c'est à dire que un peuple
qui est totalement déconstruit qui ne
sait plus qui il est qui ne sait plus où
il va ben c'est beaucoup plus facile à
manipuler que des gens qui sont
doués de réflexion doué de de
d'esprit critique ce qu'on essaie de de
d'éliminer le plus possible donc
nous avons aujourd'hui le résultat de 40
ans de d'idées d'ultra gauche qui fait
que on est en train de déconstruire tout
le monde le l'éducation c'est typique
aujourd'hui on est on est on a des
problèmes d'éducation on a des problèmes
de personnel on a des problèmes
de de de de de
de d'harcèlement on a des problèmes de
tout ça ça passe à côté de de
l'enseignement
de l'éducation sexuelle et du kamasutra
par Monsieur Papa donc on a on a un vrai
problème il fait pas ça mais si mais si
mais si je suis désolé je suis désolé
minutes
on aborde
melien on aborde beaucoup de sujets
premièrement c'est moi une question de
personnes qu'une personne d'idée et
l'idée
mais tu vas nous apprendre des choses
ils continuent merci
c'est moi une question de personne qui
est une question d'idées ça c'est le
premier point c'est pas tellement les
gens quand vous avez été formé et éduqué
par exemple tu prends l'exemple de la
finalement de la contradiction c'est
vrai que c'est un des problèmes de nos
sociétés quand aujourd'hui quand vous
contredisez quelqu'un c'est perçu comme
un acte de désamour
un acte de désamour il y a si quelqu'un
me contredit c'est qu'il ne m'aime pas
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe je le
rejette voire je l'élimine ça c'est
dangereux c'est dangereux en fait parce
que quand on veut construire une société
il faut progresser en faut innover on a
que ce mot-là à la bouche innover
innover innover mais l'innovation c'est
quoi c'est pas que de la technique c'est
pas de queue du progrès technologique
c'est assumer en fait le débat
contradictoire pourquoi j'ai besoin de
la contradiction pour continuer à
innover parce que si chaque jour qui
passe je déblatère en fait mon discours
avec un argumentaire qui est
relativement épais et je sais que chaque
jour qui passe j'ai personne qui va
jamais me contredire et ben je finis par
m'endormir et me répéter sans même
m'interroger si ce que je dis est
valable premier élément important avoir
en tête quand on parle tu parles de
référentiel en fait en réalité tu dis
tous nos référentiels sont en train de
disparaître en voilà un aujourd'hui la
contradiction est perçue comme un acte
des amours c'est faux et je suis je vais
vous dire pourquoi à quel point je suis
convaincu que c'est faux la
contradiction c'est ce qui nous fait
avancer c'est pour ça que je continue en
fait de chercher et de trouver c'est la
perspective de trouver quelqu'un qui va
me dire le contraire donc me faire
progresser c'est pour ça que je continue
de travailler c'est pour ça que je vais
encore un peu aller un peu plus loin
dans le cadre de la réflexion
oui alors sauf que aujourd'hui ça c'est
vrai la seule chose qu'on fait dès qu'il
y a un contradicteur en les limites en
l'élimine du champ médiatique qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas c'est pas le sujet mais
l'éliminer c'est un acte dangereux parce
que c'est ce qui nous prive de notre
capacité à innover tous les gens
aujourd'hui limite l'innovation a un
progrès technologique et technique c'est
d'abord un progrès intellectuel c'est
d'abord en fait à volonté de continuer à
avancer à progresser et je vous dis à
quel point je suis convaincu de cela je
vais raconter un peu mon histoire
personnelle et à quel point c'est une
hérésie complète et c'est bien bien du
fait en fait qu'on se connaît plus et
qu'on fantasme en fait les hommes et les
femmes en fait qui nous entourent
aujourd'hui et qu'on les connaît plus
véritablement moi j'ai grandi dans une
famille matriarcale les hommes dans ma
famille sont tous morts jeunes et il y
avait une figure tété l'air qui
s'appelait une grand-mère comme tout à
chacun voilà et grand-mère était
vraiment une figure centrale elle a eu
elle a été veuve car la plus vieille de
ces cinq filles avait 8 ans
[Musique]
et je t'embrasse mamie je sais que tu
vas regarder ce soir vas-y continue et
donc cette figure tu t’élère donc dans
un village là où je vis d'ailleurs
village dans je suis conseil municipal
aussi oui on peut rester acteur quelle
que soit l'endroit en fait où on
travaille donc ça c'est une question de
volonté mais dans ce lieu dans cette
famille matriarcale chez ma grand-mère
tous les dimanches soirs là que la terre
portait et bien on se rassemblait toute
la famille élargie les oncles les tentes
les cousins etc et vous savez j'ai
observé quand j'étais gamin quelque
chose de formidable des engueulades tous
les dimanches soirs
intellectuel parisien pardon ça
s'engueulait un chat sa pensée très à
droite ça pensait très à gauche à passer
très en haut ça pensait très en bas ça
personne était d'accord sur rien et
pourtant les gens s'aimaient et je
aimerais juste les gens retiennent cette
chose là c'est que la contradiction
n'est pas un acte de désamour je peux ne
pas être d'accord avec toi tout en
t'aimant je peux ne pas être d'accord
avec Olivier tout en l'aimant et c'est
le vrai sujet non mais le vrai sujet il
est là il y a une forme de confusion et
cette confusion elle n'est aussi de la
distance qui s'est créée entre moi et
parfois enfin en tout cas entre une
sphère notamment une sphère en fait
politique qui décide et la population en
tant que telle et j'ai peur aujourd'hui
que cette conviction forte qu'il y a de
l'amour entre eux je parle pas des roses
évidemment un mot fille vieille en fait
une vraie relation forte un vieux
respect un vrai amour fait
qu'aujourd'hui en fait une forme de
défiance qui s'est créée et que dès que
j'ai la contradiction je le prends pour
moi comme une attaque personnelle et
j'élimine et ça c'est dangereux parce
que ça nous ça nous prive de deux choses
la capacité est capacité à rester
connecté à écouter mon contradicteur et
deux à continuer à travailler parce que
je voudrais parce que l'homme est les
femmes sont faites telles que on a envie
d'avoir raison je continuerai à
travailler pour trouver un contrat
argument et donc ça il faut quand même
la voir en tête on parle de référentiel
on peut les prendre les uns après les
autres mais celui-ci est très important
il faut réapprendre à se contredire
réapprendre réapprenant à nous engueuler
c'est énorme ce n'est pas un acte de
désamour ce n'est pas pour ça en fait
qu'on ne s'aime pas pierre tu poses une
question Olivier
Olivier aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui fait
que
tu penses qu'on n'y arrivera pas
Bruno Le Maire non mais ça peut être une
question
de personne c'est une question de pardon
c'est une question de de voir la dérive
totale de de la société actuelle et
alors justement je vais rebondir sur ce
que tu viens de dire aujourd'hui
c'est vachement sensé ce qu'il a dit
c'est très censé mais je vais rebondir
dessus et je vais apporter de l'eau à
son moulin en plus c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui le il y a plus de dialogue
pour la bonne et simple raison que dès
que quelqu'un ne colle pas au narratif
et bien c'est un affreux fasciste c'est
un affreux extrêmeiste c'est le niveau
zéro de de l'intelligence si tu le sais
voilà dès que dès que tu as dit quelque
chose qui ne collait pas au narratif et
bien tu es exclu et on refuse de te
parler on pas là récemment vu le
ministre de l'Éducation le ministre de
la de la
communication qui nous a de pas de la
communication de la culture qui a qui a
dit que
c'est news était d'extrême droite et que
donc il fallait couper ses news donc
tout ce qui n'est pas dans le le moule
c'est d'extrême droite donc faut le
couper exactement et c'est ça moi ça me
faisait bondir à peu près tous les jours
quand j'entends des ça pendant le covid
c'est que dès que tu posais une question
tu remettais pas en cause quoi que ce
soit tu posais une question et bien à ce
moment-là on disait mais tu n'as pas
confiance dans la science et ça veut
dire quoi confiance dans la science la
science c'est quoi c'est se poser des
questions c'est ne pas se c'est surtout
ne jamais arrêter se poser des questions
or là on t'affirmé quelque chose comme
si c'était la vérité et tu n'avais pas
le droit de poser la moindre question
par rapport à ça en disant mais est-ce
que voilà est-ce que vous trouvez ça
normal que est-ce que etc et là tout de
suite tu étais exclu tu étais antivax
donc tu étais marqué tu étais antivacs
et on te disait mais c'est la science
mais non la science c'est se poser des
questions en permanence je peux t'ouvrir
une parenthèse avec l'autorisation de
Pierre mets-toi à la place d'un État qui
potentiellement voit une saloperie de
sortir d'un laboratoire voix
potentiellement le fait que ces stocks
ont été gérés comme des Pieds Nickelés
nonchalants et que on n'a pas de masque
on n'a pas de tubulure on n'a pas tout
ce qu'il faut des consommables pour
gérer une pandémie
c'est prévoir tes vilains tu es possédé
il gouverne pas il gère
c'est quelle logique pour avoir absorbé
tant de bêtises mais c'est une certitude
mais quand on voit que les pharmaciens
pouvaient pas vendre des masques on est
d'accord
essaye d'être un peu bienveillant
vas-y je dis je dis simplement non non
mais je suis pas bienveillant pas du
tout faites venir l'exorciste
simplement je rebondissais sur ce que
sur ce que Pierre avait dit c'est-à-dire
que tant que tu n'auras pas
tant que le on aura une absence totale
d'esprit critique tant qu'on aura une
absence totale de de
contre-pouvoir de contre de contre
réflexion c'est à dire des gens qui
posent des questions des gens qui
s'interrogent je parle même pas d'être
contre non je parle simplement de
s'interroger de dire bah ok tu me dis ça
ok je veux bien mais excuse-moi je vais
aller quand même chercher je vais aller
quand même vérifier je vais aller quand
même bon
là le discours officiel est vérifié par
qui il
est vérifié par trois olibrius qui
sortent de nulle part qui ne savent rien
sur rien et qui décrète que c'est vrai
ou c'est pas vrai qui distribue des bons
points à des prix Nobels à des machins
mais alors que ils sont battent moins 15
mais c'est pas grave et donc c'est
aujourd'hui on a une seule voie et on
essaie de et le gouvernement et c'est de
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait plus qu'une
seule voie
et il est en train petit à petit de
bloquer tout ce qui pourrait réfléchir
et tout ce qui pourrait dire peut-être
qu'on peut se poser une question
alors moi c'est symptomatique
la prochaine question ce sera sur
l'Europe sur
Ursula et et sur ce qui nous gère je
t'en prie alors ce qui est symptomatique
c'est quoi en fait c'est symptomatique
d'un état d'esprit moi je juge pas les
gens qui sont au pouvoir ça c'est pas
moi de le faire j'ai pas la légitimité
pour le faire etc évidemment mais
je évidemment c'est vrai et ça c'est un
sujet enfin ce qui m'est très très cher
c'est c'est savoir quel est son rôle
tout à l'heure j'ai parlé en fait d'un
élément simple qui est la puissance de
l'écoute de la taille etc il y a un
autre trait de caractère de la société
tel qu'on l'a dessiné c'est qu'elle est
très ce qu'on appelle Top Down très
descendante je sais et en fait les gens
après derrière vont diffuser et
disséminées
parce qu'il y a deux éléments
relativement importants avoir en tête
c'est que un cette conviction là elle
est peut être efficace je la juge pas le
fait l'aspect descendant autoritaire je
sais vous allez en fait faire ça marche
ça peut marcher dans un pays ça peut
marcher dans une boîte mais ça marche
quand rien ne bouge quand j'ai juste en
fait à faire quelque chose qui
fonctionne et que je vais répéter et là
oui ça peut fonctionner mais quand en
fait ce que je faisais par le passé
n'est plus adapté continuez de faire ça
c'est terrible et je vais vous donner un
exemple pour ça ça a un élément
important à avoir en tête et qui me rend
encore optimiste
c'est la France
c'est la France dans le passé tout à
l'heure j'ai parlé de la fin du 19ème
siècle à bien des égards je vais pas
m'étendre sur le sujet mais le c'est une
époque qui ressemble beaucoup en fait à
la période actuelle pourquoi parce que
tous les référentiels sautent révolution
technique majeure je rappelle un fait
qu'à l'époque machine à vapeur c'est
quoi révolution de transport électricité
et donc révolution de transport
télégraphe révolution de communication
premier mouvement délocalisation en fait
de l'histoire c'est la première fois de
l'histoire qu'on déconnecte le lieu de
consommation du lieu de production avant
c'était pas le cas donc évidemment en
pleine métier qui disparaisse d'autres
qui réapparaissent c'est pas le besoin
qui a changé c'est la manière de
m'ouvrir répondre naturellement le monde
d'avant le modèle d'organisation d'avant
est plus adapté les populations changent
les gens migrent vers les villes en fait
voilà je vais pas refaire l'histoire
mais tout ça fait que progressivement
les populations changent et modèles
organisations est toujours celui du
passé face à ça il a aboutit à quoi ce
monde un monde de tension terrible
tension de quelle origine tension
politique va se gouvernement partout
dans le monde évidemment attention
sociale avec des problématiques de
tension sociale qui aiment émerge qui
font émerger d'ailleurs la notion de
syndicalisme c'est à cette époque là
tension entrepreneuriale les boîtes se
bouffent les unes les autres si tout à
l'heure j'évoquais les trusts les gafam
de l'époque c'est pas de l'esprit c'est
naturellement car la taille du gâteau à
se partager augmente
individuellement je veux continuer à
grossir donc je bouffe les uns on se
bouffe les uns les autres et ça castagne
et ça amène en fait à des grains à une
grosse tension aussi entrepreneuriale
tension terroriste tiens bizarrement à
l'époque d'origine anarchiste mais aussi
qui était extrêmement vivace en gros un
monde percute tension pourquoi c'est ma
fameuse tectonique des plaques
progressivement le monde tel que je
l'avais conçu par le passé n'est plus
adapté à ce que nous devenons tant que
vous réadapter un pas en fait le modèle
d'organisation ça marche pas deux
réponses à l'époque de réponses
historiques c'est vachement intéressant
1 un vote politique effectivement face à
l'incapacité un pays face à l'incapacité
à comprendre que ça marche plus et qu'il
faut reconstruire et bien décide
n'arrive pas à changer et fait un vote à
l'époque c'est les États-Unis qui ont
fait ce de radicalité politique qui
était celle en fait d'élire Théodore
Roosevelt dans le seul programme en 1901
était je découperai les gros face à
l'incapacité d'avoir su appréhender ce
changement là je découperai les gros je
Jean-Luc Mélenchon des temps anciens
pour le coup ok bon mais ça a amené en
fait à une décennie un peu compliquée
c'est
je tends le bâton pour faire battre
c'est le plaisir le plaisir le plaisir
de la contradiction je vous passe les
plats messieurs
première élément en fait un pays qui
arrive pas un autre qui a réussi vous
savez qu'elle sait
le bouton la France en fait beaucoup de
gens pensent que le modèle français
était conçu post Seconde Guerre mondiale
c'est faux en réalité le modèle français
et l'essence l'essentiel en fait de nos
fondations repose du début du 20e
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait à l'époque face à
cette nécessité de se reconstruire parce
que rien fonctionner on a fait quoi on
en a foutu la paix aux gens en fait on a
reconstruit le modèle non du haut vers
le bas mais du bas vers le haut et je
vais vous expliquer comment à travers
des prises de décision qui étaient
radicales 1 la loi de 1900 la loi des
associations quand vous devez vous
reconstruire et que vous savez pas
comment vous reconstruire et bien le
seul objectif que vous avez c'est quoi
c'est libérer l'énergie c'est faire que
toute personne qui veut prendre une
initiative dans ce monde complexe puisse
la prendre et bien la réalité c'est
qu'en fait la loi 1901 la loi des
associations elle est extrêmement
radicale ainsi l'innovation politique
radicale qui a permis en fait de faire
ça loi 1905 rappelez-moi comment le
système agricole s'est organisé pour
répondre aux nouveaux besoins de
l'époque vous rappelez ça
avec des intrants et de la pétrochimie à
l'époque coopérative agricole face en
fait en gros les besoins de l'époque qui
sont des besoins globaux que chaque
agriculteur agriculteur peut pas
adresser qu'est-ce qu'on fait on fait
pas le choix du global ou du local on
réconcilie les deux en inventant la
coopérative agricole c'est quoi la
coopère agricole c'est je reste
propriétaire de chez soi mais je fais
ensemble pour adresser une question
globale c'est pas novateur ça c'est pas
c'est pas radical première élément
deuxième élément face à la capacité des
banques de l'époque à financer cette
reconstruction comment les corporations
s'organisent ça vient pas du haut vers
le bas c'est quoi le Crédit Agricole le
Crédit Agricole je fais pas de pub pour
les marques parce que les Banques
Populaires les caisses
les caisses d'épargne etc c'est la même
chose c'est quoi c'est des agriculteurs
qui se mettent ensemble pour financer
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
les corps les corporations s'organisent
pour créer leur propre organes de
financement le mutualisme non mais au
début je ne change pas mais je veux
juste vous faire comprendre que
un maximum on pose la question plus tard
désolé je veux juste vous montrer en
vous montrant cet exemple c'est une
manière en fait de ne pas rester les
bras ballants en se disant qu'on ira
jamais la France a su le faire face à ce
besoin de reconstruction nous avons su
créer un modèle résilient qui aura
presque durer un siècle il est fini
c'est pas grave nous avons su le faire
en fait l'enjeu et le même et le
challenge et le même qu'à l'époque se
reconstruire mais juste pour vous dire
que tout à l'heure je parlais de la
notion de la contradiction nécessaire à
l'innovation c'est un élément majeur et
deuxièmement cette conviction forte qui
est que la reconstruction ne peut se
fait jamais du haut vers le bas mais
toujours du bas vers le haut donc notre
valeur elle est où elle est pas dans la
tête elle est dans nos pieds notre
valeur elle est au plus profond de notre
territoire pour comprendre ce que sont
de nos populations leurs capacité leurs
qualités leurs défauts qu'il ne faut pas
nier et les éléments en fait qui vont
nous permettre de capitaliser sur leurs
qualités et pas sur leur défaut c'est
vrai chez les gens c'est vrai sur les
territoires ça fait combien de temps en
fait qu'on tape sur les communes les
communes ça fait bien trop longtemps il
se trouve que je suis conseiller
municipal une toute petite commune donc
je suis si ça vous intéresse je peux
vous en parler en fait de ce qu'est la
vie au quotidien d'une toute petite
commune mon père et mère d'un petit
village à côté vice-président de
l'agglomération et donc c'est vraiment
du terrain là dont je vous parle mais la
réalité c'est que la reconstruction de
ce fait là encore pas à Paris pour aller
dire ce qu'il faut faire en fait au fin
fond de l'Auvergne hard sur coup si vous
connaissez le Tour de France est passé
aujourd'hui mais c'est hard surcouze
qu'on sait ce qu'il faut ce qu'on est et
du coup ce qu'il faut pour
révéler son plein potentiel et en fait
le vrai sujet donc c'est d'être persuadé
qu'une chose c'est une chose est sûre
c'est que je ne sais pas et je dois
faire confiance au terrain pour faire
émerger des solutions à ta droite il y a
un auvergnat qui pense que bottom up du
bas vers le haut
l'Europe
Ursula vanderleyen le Conseil de
l'Europe le machin de l'Europe de bidule
de l'Europe que on donne des taxes à
l'Europe est-ce que tu vas réussir à
réconcilier l'Auvergnat qui est à ta
droite avec Ursula non mais le problème
c'est c'est ça si tu veux c'est que à la
fin du 19e d'abord la France était
souveraine
ce qu'elle n'est plus aujourd'hui et on
avait beaucoup moins de strates
or aujourd'hui on a fait un
mille-feuille
et le haut du mille-feuille c'est
l'Europe
enfin même pas aller plus loin mais on
peut traverser l'Atlantique mais
en fait le c'est ça qui nous met un
problème de plus alors je veux pas dire
qu'on va pas y arriver je dis simplement
que il faut déjà éliminer le
millefeuille chez nous et en plus il
faut éliminer la feuille supérieure qui
est l'Europe je veux dire tu ne peux pas
partir du moment où tout ce qui se
décide en France vient en fait de
directives de l'Europe
aujourd'hui je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est
Ursula vanderlayen qui décide c'est
Ursula vont droit de prononcer ce prénom
dans cette émission quand elle aura
rendu public ses SMS donc ça restera
juste
Ursula
Ursula alors Ursula la bonne Ursula
c'est elle qui dirige c'est elle qui je
rappelle puisque j'ai été directement
concerné mais c'est elle qui annonce la
fermeture de RT c'est pas la recom
donne le le feu vert donne la fréquence
à RT en décembre en février c'est pas
l'arcome qui dit attention il y a
quelque chose qui va pas etc c'est même
pas monsieur Macron c'est wanderleyen
qui l'annonce donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que c'est elle qui décide
c'est elle qui décide d'envoyer des
armes à l'Ukraine au départ c'est elle
qui décide de
de
confisquer les biens de de leader russe
pourquoi quand a raison
ah mais à tort totalement c'est-à-dire
que tu ne peux pas en absence de tout
problème juridique
quand tu as un pays qui viole la
souveraineté d'un autre pays
c'est terminé
alors je vais te je vais te dire
Paris on fait la guerre à la Belgique
ne nous a pas envahi non mais elle
envahit
l'Ukraine oui mais on n'est pas en
guerre de la France que je sache n'a pas
il n'y a pas eu de déclaration de guerre
entre la France et la Russie on est bien
d'accord par le monde donc non je suis
désolé mais jusqu'à présent
tu n'as pas de base juridique
à saisir quoi que ce soit comme bien des
Russes
donc c'est la Chine
c'est parce que disent les Américains
donc ça veut dire que le jour où
l'annexion est officielle de Taïwan par
la Chine qu'est-ce qui se passe il se
passe qu'on va saisir les biens des
Chinois en France
en terme de droit international Taïwan
c'est quoi
c'est reconnu par quel pays
l'Ukraine s'est reconnu par beaucoup
plus de pays quand même mais tu verras
qu'il se passera exactement la même
chose
le sujet il se passera exactement la
même chose c'est à dire que le jour où
les Chinois parce que les Américains de
l'accepteront pas parce que pourquoi
tout simplement parce que la Taïwan
c'est quoi c'est les
semi-conducteurs bon et donc les
Américains peuvent pas laisser faire
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
les Américains feront ce qu'il faudra
pour essayer d'aller
emmerder les Chinois ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que on te dira à ce
moment-là et bien on saisit les biens
des Chinois il y a quelque chose de
légal là-dedans non rien qu'est-ce qui
va se passer
mais qu'est-ce qui va se passer il va se
passer d'abord que tu n'auras plus aucun
étranger qui investir en France parce
que le gars il est pas fou c'est très
bien ce qui va se passer donc il
n'investira plus en France mais surtout
comme tu n'as aucune base légale
et bien la prochaine fois c'est parce
que tu auras regardé notre grand leader
de travers qu'on va se confisquer
charismatique qu'on va te confier tes
avoir
il n'y a pas plus de raison
puisque tu es déjà hors l'égalité
tu peux faire tu peux tout faire et donc
tu n'as plus le droit de propriété en
France ça n'existe fait référence à
l'état d'urgence de réquisition de
comment ça s'appelle ça comment ça
s'appelle ça c'est pour solvabiliser la
dette française c'est pour faire quoi ça
on parle de quoi là alors on parle un de
la loi de programmation militaire ça
c'est une chose la deuxième chose dont
on parle c'est c'est le fait de en fait
de nationaliser la terre c'est à dire de
te faire payer un loyer
donc à une sorte de baille en phytéotie
comme tu l'as en Angleterre et donc de
te faire payer un loyer quand tu es
propriétaire d'une maison parce que tu
vas louer la terre et bien tout ça est
une atteinte au droit sacrés puisque je
rappelle que c'est dans la Constitution
et que c'est aussi c'est dans les droits
de l'homme de propriété mais la
propriété aujourd'hui n'existe plus
grâce à notre grand
en fait le vrai sujet pour nous n'est
pas ni Europe ou autre il faut toujours
un peu avant moi je suis un peu fâché
par Ursula parce que celui-là elle passe
des contraintes des milliards avec notre
pognon et qu'elle fait ça par SMS et que
et que ces SMS ils sont pas rendus
public et alors ça me fâche beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup
et que et que je l'entends parler que je
l'entends qui va être bombardé peut-être
à l'OTAN et que je l'entends que machin
que c'est super bien qu'il est super
belle sauf que la parole du CSMS publics
et que quand on négocie un contrat de
cette taille là
ça me paraît bien fâcheux alors la
première question que je vais te poser
c'est comment ça se fait que Ursula
vanderleyen n'a pas publié ses SMS
concernant la gestion des contrats des
vaccins covid c'est normal c'est pas
normal c'est du foutage de gueule est-ce
qu'il faut la trapper
l'emmener dans notre frontière et lui
dire maintenant tu es plus à Bruxelles
ici tu es en France on va t'expliquer
comment ça se passe la négociation de
contrat public
tu es pas contente on va t'expliquer
deux fois plus vite c'est pas à moi de
répondre à ta question maintenant ce que
je sais j'ai dit d'ailleurs en plateau
je crois que c'était avec le patron de
l'agir Carco ici c'est que en fait tout
responsable qu'il soit doit avoir en
fait un niveau d'exemplarité qui soit
total aujourd'hui on parlait de
référentiel on était quand elle était en
Allemagne
tu fais référence à ce que tu veux mais
la notion clé c'est la voilà il y a du
fric qui circule c'est la notion
d'exemplarité et je vais plus loin pour
éviter l'amalgame de tous pourris et
bien la seule solution c'est quoi c'est
d'être extrêmement justement avec ceux
qui triche et en l'occurrence et ça
c'est alors je vais vous donner une
petite anecdote
plus personne alors là
de cheveux encore ce j'ai un petit
bracelet électronique qui je suis qui
suis-je si je peux me permettre
la la députée européenne qui s'était
fait gauler au Qatar avec plusieurs
millions dans sa chambre
elle était vice-président de la
commission si mes souvenirs sont mon jeu
demande à me faire factic d'accord donc
regarde je pense que elle a réintégré sa
son boulot donc elle a pas atterré en
prison
mais on les attrape à la française avec
ce côté un petit peu
charismatique français du genre on va
leur écoute-moi tu vas t'asseoir là on
va t'expliquer que tu t'es bien foutu de
notre gueule et quand tu vas ressortir
jamais tu auras envie de souiller le nom
France dans quelle époque tu vis je
pense que Robespierre et
mariner là dessus ça c'est un vrai une
vraie question méthodologique on peut
parler en fait toute la soirée
de la CIA à côté par rapport à ce que
j'ai dans la tête en terme de métaux de
logis ça reste mais c'est pas la
pratique actuelle c'est pas la pratique
actuelle venez me chercher si c'est pas
la j'en doute pas mais c'est pas la
pratique actuelle mais je dis souvent en
fait on peut parler de toute la soirée
en fait de grandes généralités mais là
soyons précis la question en fait et le
point soulevé et la question de la
responsabilité du preneur décision
publique et quand tu dis c'est la France
pour moi en fait le problème presque
c'est pas la France c'est la manière
dont on voit les choses en France la
réalité c'est
réintégrer ou pas alors il va cailler il
y a toujours bon on va pas faire du même
camping
ça arrive alors du coup je peux je peux
répondre ou non d'accord et donc la
question en fait c'est à partir du
moment où les gens doivent être
responsables si les gens trichent il
faut émettre en fait des sanctions qui
font que plus jamais pas ceux qui ont
triché n'est plus envie de le faire ils
ont évidemment les sanctions sont
évidemment non et quand tu dis en fait
la prison la prison sert plus à rien
c'est faux dans le monde non la prison
sert plus à rien chez les petites gens
mais la prison en fait elle sert au
contraire justement dans la société
élevée parce qu'aujourd'hui on fait
faire quoi en général comme ça qu'est-ce
qu'on donne comme sanction à ces gens-là
un bracelet et un chèque mais le chat
qui fait pas mal qu'est-ce que la valeur
d'une sanction elle sert à quoi elle
sert pas à punir elle sert
essentiellement à dire à tous les autres
regardez si vous le faites vous aurez
mal et vous aurez honte et le vrai sujet
c'est aujourd'hui en fait qu'il faut
redéfinir le rôle de la sanction aussi
au regard de la sociologie des personnes
dont on parle et la réalité mais la
réalité c'est qu'au contraire la prison
elle est la vraie prison serait très
utile pour justement les gens qui sont
semblant et pas un col bleu pour le coup
parce que la réalité de ces gens-là que
la prison c'est dissuasif est-ce qu'il
faut pas passer
absolument certain parce que tu sais
dans ce monde là qui est mon monde aussi
c'est que véritablement la chose qui
compte le plus c'est l'image qu'on
renvoie auprès de ses paires n'oublions
jamais en fait cela c'est que qu'est-ce
qui vaut quelque chose le bonheur
relatif et on a tellement construit des
ghettos et donc aujourd'hui le ghetto de
preneur de décision c'est un ghetto en
fait tout le monde se ressemble dans ce
cadre là et bien la réalité c'est que la
chose la plus importante c'est l'image
qu'on envoie dans sa propre communauté
et donc la notion de présence en fait ça
aurait plus important je dis pas qu'il
faut mettre sur celui en prison c'est
pas le sujet mais la notion de
responsabilités
à ce à quoi sert en fait la sanction la
sanction sert à être dissuasif pour tous
les autres c'est sa valeur d'exemple
après je dis pas les modalités de et ça
je pense
mais interrogeons-nous par rapport à
cela si on ne fait pas ça concrètement
il y a plus que deux solutions soit on
ne fait rien et là pour le coup c'est
tous pourri parce qu'il y a des
amalgames systématiques et il n'y a plus
de moyens en fait de disséminer le doute
d'éliminer le doute parce que le doute
devient partout ou alors il y a une
autre chose qui est très français très
français ces phases à un comportement
des viandes je considère que du coup
tout le monde est déviant et je crée une
loi une règle ou une norme qui fait que
je pénalise tout le monde face à au
manque de courage de contrôler
sanctionner je fais une loi qui va
pénaliser tout le monde et va encore un
peu plus étouffer étouffer notre
capacité à pouvoir créer la communauté
on peut prendre la main dans le sac des
tricheurs qui changent des règles comme
ça ça les arrange ils changent les
règles
c'est quand même tout à l'heure dans
votre dialogue sur la notion en fait de
Sénégal ou pas légal je mettrai juste
toujours en perspective le fait que qui
crée le droit
c'est pas un droit divin il est pas
enfin oui sur une plaque ça peut être
écrire une époque mais aujourd'hui en
fait c'est nous qui l'avons créé donc
attention à tout mettre sur l'eau à
l'eau du droit le droit il est il est
aussi évolutif parce qu'il est écrit par
des hommes et des femmes que nous sommes
donc il faut faire attention à cela dans
le sens où il est évolutif et croire que
parce que c'est aujourd'hui écrit comme
cela dans le droit ça sera éternellement
comme cela ça peut être dangereux parce
que bah le droit peut être amené à
changer mais la question de la
responsabilité est au cœur de tout alors
maintenant si je peux me permettre de
répondre parce que c'est la suite
logique de ce que ce que tu évoqué sur
la notion de Europe versus territoire en
fait aujourd'hui il y a deux sujets
simples en fait en complexifie tout mais
c'est simple on a deux sujets adressés
le local est global
aujourd'hui notre monde caricature ce
discours c'est soit vous êtes local soit
vous êtes global il n'y a pas en fait de
réconciliation des deux jamais soit vous
êtes dans le camp des local soit dans le
camp du global et les uns pour les uns
le bien c'est cela pour les autres biens
le mal inversement la réalité c'est
qu'en fait il faut qu'on réponde à ces
deux questions là qui est le plus à même
de régler les problématiques du local
comment on le définit qui est les plus à
même de régler la problématique du
globale le local c'est quoi c'est un
lieu enfin nous la manière dont on
définit je vais prendre du haut quel est
le prospective c'est le local c'est
quand c'est un territoire dans lequel tu
es susceptible de croiser quelqu'un dans
une journée donc ça se définit même
techniquement voilà c'est le local c'est
quoi bah c'est la commune lieu de vie
l'agglomération probablement il y a un
espace dans lequel tu es susceptible de
te croiser ça c'est le local parce que
tu partages quelque chose avec tes
concitoyens qui s'appelle un lieu pas
descendre d'intérêt mais un lieu donc ça
ça c'est le local c'est probablement le
bon échelon après tout le reste tout le
reste c'est quoi c'est le département
peut-être pas mais les régions l'état
l'Europe s'adresse quoi comme question
la région Rhône-Alpes qui est formidable
c'est laquelle dans laquelle je c'est la
région dans laquelle je vis mais
franchement tu penses sincèrement que ça
c'est un échelon qui n'est pas trop
grand pour adresser les problématiques
locales est-ce qu'il y a un point commun
entre les problématiques des gens qui
vivent horillac et à Aix-les-Bains et je
vais plus loin en faisant des grandes
régions de ce type est-ce que le gars
qui est bénévole dans un club de rugby
tiens je le prends au hasard évidemment
donc qui qui entraîne les gamins dans un
club de rugby qui va avoir en fait son
assemblée générale régionale à
Aix-les-Bains tu crois vraiment qu'il va
y aller le samedi
non donc en fait la question
fondamentale c'est qu'elle est en gros
l'échelon qui adresse le Global
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup trop de
compétitions sur l'échelon global on a
les régions on a l'état on a l'Europe je
dis une seule chose on en a besoin que
dans voilà donc faut choisir je vais pas
de politique c'est à vous en fait de
choisir mais en tout cas la réalité
c'est que on a besoin d'un échelon local
assumé c'est la commune et la réunion de
commune qui s'appelle une agglomération
et après on a besoin d'un échange global
et les grandes régions en ce sens sont
une anachronisation sont totalement
anachroniques en France parce que
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont fait sous l'homme
de la décentralisation en fait elles ont
recréé des territoires qui sont si
puissants qu'ils sont des petits États
donc en réalité dans un même état on a
créé les on a créé en fait en interne
une compétition pour adresser les
questions globales la région Rhône-Alpes
est aujourd'hui suffisamment puissante
pour être un concurrent légitime de
l'État et bien d'une certaine manière je
suis pas sûr qu'on soit sur le chemin de
la simplification ou de la
décomplexification
vous comprenez que les gens les gens ne
comprennent rien
c'est à dire les Chelon
communal
d'agglomération etc
c'est un plateauoyé en faveur de d'un
retour à La Souvenance à la souveraineté
parce que de la même façon quand tu as
une Europe qui gère
ce qu'elle gère aujourd'hui 27 pays
comment veux-tu que un allemand n'a pas
les mêmes
problématiques et les mêmes aspirations
et qu'un grecs ou un Grec qu'un italien
ou qu'un espagnol un français donc
qu'on retrouve l'échelle en effet
régional enfin même plus que plus petit
que la région parce que je suis assez
d'accord sur le fait que dans la région
Bourgogne Franche-Comté si tu veux le
village dans lequel j'habite 550 8 ans
et Dijon c'est pas franchement la même
chose
on se tire pas encore dessus à la
chenikov à l'étoile donc
voilà c'est plus chez toi je sais bien
donc
tu ne peux pas faire non plus si tu
prônes ça au niveau
communauté d'agglomération etc tu ne
peux pas le prôner au niveau de l'Europe
c'est la même chose
pour conclure sur le sujet
ça dure pas trois jours non mais ça fait
déjà 1h30
n'oubliez pas que ce soir nous partons
en vacances donc j'aimerais qu'on parle
un peu de Bruno Le Maire et de son
dernier et de son dernier ouvrage
concernant le le dilaté comme jamais le
renflement brun le prix de la des des
inflation
de Bruno Le Maire important
c'est-à-dire qu'un réalité il faut qu'on
reconstruise complètement du bas il faut
qu'on inverse la pyramide dans une
commune une agglomération c'est quoi ça
me rassemblement de merde
s'il te plaît après je t'expliquerai
comment on peut faire c'est pas
compliqué
quelque chose quand tu sais ce que tu
veux faire derrière tu sais
une date
je vais t'expliquer un peu donc va au
concret donc j'avais au concret mais
tout ça pour dire que en réalité tu n'as
besoin de l'échelon du dessus que pour
les choses que tu ne peux pas assumer
toi tout seul toujours et donc on a
oublié cela c'est à dire qu'en réalité
tu ne remonte qu'au niveau régional que
ce que tu ne peux pas assumer à neige
son départementale tu ne remonte à
l'échelon de la vibration que tu ne peux
pas assumer lâcher en communal tu ne
remonte etc etc et donc tu ne devrais
remonter comme périmètre d'action au
niveau européen que ce que tu ne peux
pas assumer au niveau national et en
fait on a fait on a passé ça fait 50 ans
qu'on a construit quelque chose qui est
tout à l'envers donc pour nous aider à
faire des choses qu'on ne pourrait pas
assumer tout seul en réalité en passant
son temps à construire des fédérations
qui ne qui passent leur temps en réalité
à étouffer les entités qu'elles sont
censées fédérer l'intégration de la
Turquie dans l'Union européenne ça se
passe bien
tu as besoin de répondre comme tu veux
en fait
pourquoi faire c'est quoi c'est quoi
l'objectif ça dépend si tu dois négocier
un contrat pour immobiliser 2 millions
et demi de réfugiés ça peut se négocier
un peu un peu comme l'effet miroir qui
après ils disent que la Suède tout va
bien pour l'OTAN on est on en est arrivé
ça s'appelle ça s'appelle la démocratie
la diplomatie de marchand de tapis
en avant et qu'est-ce qui se passe tu
donnes le doigt
voilà on prend la main on prend la main
l'avant-bras puis le bras c'est pas en
fait tant que là typiquement la question
des réfugiés attaquants n'a pas compris
la source
faite on n'arrivera jamais c'est comme
les dopage et le contrat le contrôle
antido pas il y en a toujours un qui a
un temps d'avance donc c'est peine
perdue alors je salue les gens qui
essaient de trouver des solutions en
étant de mettre des voilà des pansements
voilà mais sur des gens de bois en fait
et donc la réalité c'est qui on peut pas
en fait se satisfaire de cela parce que
d'une certaine manière on ne fait que
reculer l'échéance et si je dois donner
je dois donner une analogie c'est comme
en physique tu sais en physique tu as
une politique inéquation et qui
équilibré en est et elle à un moment
donné les déséquilibrer donc
il faut que les paramètres s'ajustent
pour en fait pour que on retente vers
une nouvelle position d'équilibre mais
c'est pas obligatoire si tu injectes
suffisamment d'énergie pour stabiliser
la position déséquilibres et bien tant
que tu injeques de l'énergie chez nous
c'est du pognon ou ça peut être d'aller
diplomatie tant que tu en as tant que tu
en as et que tu en injecte ta position
qui déséquilibré et bien les stables
donc tu as l'illusion de l'équilibre
mais la réalité c'est que le jour où tu
manques d'énergie du jour au lendemain
si t'as plu à cette énergie du jour au
lendemain ta position déséquilibre se
révèle et tu retomber brutalement vers
la position d'équilibre donc c'est en
cela en fait aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment la planche à bille qui est la
nouvelle énergie voilà avant il y avait
l'énergie qui était pétrole etc ce qu'on
connaît et on a on a cru à partir de de
2000 comme bien d'enchaîner derrière
avec ça commencez dit comme comment
s'est dit que il y avait on avait
dépassé le pic pétrolier que l'énergie
ça allait commencer à coûter plus cher
etc on s'est dit il faut qu'on trouve
une autre source d'énergie et là il est
génial
on a un truc
qui n'est pas une énergie fossile
qui est qui est la planche à billets et
la planche à billets c'est infini
et donc ça a été la nouvelle énergie
c'est-à-dire la dette et le et la
planche à billets donc on en abuse et
comme dit Pierre quand on veut que le le
système soit à nouveau à l'équilibre
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on injecte de
l'énergie et là on injecte de la planche
à billets et on pense que ça va durer
toute la vie et en effet le problème
c'est que ça dure longtemps c'est à dire
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que au début on
se disait que ça allait aller beaucoup
plus vite que la chute allait être
beaucoup plus rapide que ça c'est parce
que on se disait bon bah ils vont quand
même s'apercevoir que la planche à
billets ça a des conséquences que la
dette ça a des conséquences etc et en
fait ben non parce qu'il s'en foutent
parce que ils ont vu un laboratoire
extraordinaire qui s'appelait le Japon
puis se sont dit mais attends finalement
on peut aller super loin sans qu'il se
passe quelque chose de
de fondamental et donc ils se sont dit
bon bah on va tous le faire c'est moi
c'est ce que j'appelais il y a quelques
années la japonisation toutes les
banques centrales et c'est ce qui s'est
passé et il s'est passé qu'aujourd'hui
ils ont dans l'idée de se dire
finalement
tous les problèmes se règle à coup de
dette et à coup de planche à billets et
alors là ils essaient je dirais une un
petit tentative de communication parce
que ce qui s'est passé sur l'inflation
qui est ressortie tout d'un coup alors
il y a madame Lagarde qui ne sait pas
d'où elle vient l'inflation mais là
c'est Madame Lagarde madame Lagarde
c'est la patronne de la BCE qui était
passé dans des cabinets d'avocats et
comme elle parlait anglais on l'avait
bombardé
et et après on l'a bombardé à la BCE
puisque elle continue à parler anglais
mieux que les autres donc
qu'elle n'a pas fait preuve d'anglais ce
qu'elle aurait dû faire c'était mieux
pour nous et Madame Lagarde madame
Lagarde ne sait pas d'où vient
l'inflation bah oui mais il se trouve
que Madame Lagarde l'inflation elle
vient de vos erreurs quand je dis vos
erreurs les erreurs de la BCE mais aussi
erreurs que tu penses que c'est une
erreur non c'est pas que je pense que
c'est une erreur de faire tourner la
planche à billets comme comme tous les
tous les pays l'ont fait tourner c'est
une erreur je me mets à la place de
Christine elle te dirait mais si j'avais
pas fait ça à l'époque tu te rends pas
compte j'apprécie je pourrais donner mon
point de vue
s'effondrer oui
mais au moins on a on en avait sous le
pied pour
repartir si si je m'en rends compte très
bien Christine Lagarde puisque
donc
on a on a eu cette illusion et en fait
comme le dit très bien pierre ça n'est
qu'une illusion c'est-à-dire tu as
l'illusion que le système s'est
stabilisé le problème c'est que le jour
où tu arrêtes et ben on est en train
d'assister d'ailleurs à ça c'est-à-dire
que tout ce qui s'est passé là depuis
la remontée des taux d'intérêt parce
qu'on a cessé d'acheter la remontée des
taux d'intérêt est en train de détruire
l'économie réelle est en train de faire
plonger l'immobilier est en train de
faire ralentir tous les pays est en
train de mettre en récession tous les
pays
c'est pas du tout la même époque et puis
c'est pas la même c'est pas la même non
c'est pas la même problématique
excuse-moi mais Walker quand il avait
monté les taux il les avait monté à 20
%. donc c'était pas c'était pas du tout
les mêmes les mêmes zones dans
lesquelles on est en plus les pays
n'étaient pas endettés comme il le sont
aujourd'hui et ça c'est la grosse
différence que tout le monde oublie en
disant oui mais finalement on peut se
permettre une hausse des taux etc oui
d'accord on peut se permettre une hausse
des taux quand on est à 50% du PIB en
dette et bien tu mets les taux à 4 ça te
fait 2 à payer hein c'est c'est assez
simple mais quand tu es à 100%,
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah quand tu te
montes à 4 c'est 4 et quand tu es à 200%
et même bientôt 300 comme les Japonais
si tu montes à ne serait-ce qu'un ça se
fait 3% à payer et donc là c'est fini
l'histoire et donc le le c'est là le
problème et le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que on est sur des modèles de
réflexion disant oui bah la dette c'est
pas grave
les taux d'intérêt s'il monte c'est pas
grave etc mais pourquoi parce qu'il
réfléchissent encore comme il y a 20 ans
ou en effet la dette n'était pas un
problème parce qu'on avait de la
croissance à mettre en face parce que on
avait une dette qui était beaucoup plus
faible or aujourd'hui je rappelle que
sous les yeux ébahis de beaucoup de de
commentateurs et d'observateurs et bien
il s'aperçoit de ce qu'on dit Pierre et
moi depuis un bon bout de temps parce
qu'on a travaillé dessus sur la
démographie et où on a aujourd'hui une
démographie qui s'est effondrée et avec
raison d'ailleurs parce que aujourd'hui
les jeunes ont pas envie de mettre un
enfant au monde dans le monde dans
lequel on vit ce qui peut se comprendre
et oui moi j'en ai fait deux mais parce
on m'avait dit de 10 mais j'ai jamais
trouvé de 0,10 donc j'en ai fait que
deux c'est deux dis le taux de
renouvellement donc et aujourd'hui pour
vous donner une idée on est à peine un
60 en Allemagne on est à 20 en Italie on
est à 20 en Espagne on est probablement
on n'a pas encore les chiffres mais pour
moi on est entre 1,60 et 1,70 ici en
France qui a plongé et qui plonge là en
2023 donc
en Italie c'est un effondrement en au
Japon ils ont 20 ans d'avance donc c'est
aussi un effondrement or ça ça fait quoi
bah ça joue sur la croissance
potentielle ça veut dire qu'on a une
croissance potentielle très faible avec
une dette monstrueuse et aujourd'hui
avec des taux entre 3 et 4%. l'équation
n'est pas tenable
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
pour moi je le dis depuis un bon moment
on va assister très bientôt à
retournement complet des banques
centrales retournement de vestes
complets des banques centrales qui vont
être obligés de réimprimer en disant on
a essayé de maîtriser l'inflation donc
ça c'est encore que de la com on a
essayé de maîtriser l'inflation en
montant les taux mais aujourd'hui
l'équation fait que nous sommes obligés
de recommencer ils vont recommencer ils
vont te mettre les taux à zéro ou proche
de zéro et qu'est-ce qui va se passer
c'est la monnaie qui va s'effondrer
voilà terminé donc le scénario il est
écrit moi maintenant j'ai pas les dates
et je m'en fous il y a plein de gens qui
disent ouais mais ça fait des années qui
disent ça oui d'accord mais les choses
se dégradent on voit aujourd'hui les
résultats de ce qu'on disait nous en
2008 en 2009 en 2010 en 2011 on le voit
aujourd'hui alors ça a duré c'est vrai
que ça a duré et que on pensait pas moi
je pensais pas que ça durerait autant
parce que je pensais pas qu'ils iraient
jusqu'au bout
non parce que je me disais simplement
ils doivent savoir quand même les
conséquences de ce qui sont en train de
faire et j'avais une naïveté de de
d'adolescents quasiment
naïveté d'adolescent qui me faisait dire
ils peuvent pas détruire l'économie
réelle simplement pour tenir le système
et en fait
permettent un
une un fléchage de l'argent sur les sur
les
0,001% de des plus riches mais ils l'ont
fait le fait est qu'ils l'ont fait
pierre je vois que tu demandes la parole
je t'écoute tu veux rebondir
pour que les gens comprennent vraiment
en fait ce qui ce qui vient d'être dit
sur la notion d'imprimer des billets de
banque concrètement les banquiers
centraux c'est les seuls c'est la
naïveté d'olivier
oui
oui parce que alors du coup oui parce
que je vais le redire d'ailleurs
autrement
[Musique]
père de famille ça peut être une bonne
mère de famille je m'en fous en fait
c'est pas le sujet mais mais
c'est l'ancrage dans le sens où bah
d'une certaine manière le bon sens
paysan tiens on pourrait aussi dire cela
mais grosso modo il se passe quoi
imagine toi tu as une machine à imprimer
des billets de banque dans ta cave tu
descends dans ta cave tu les imprimes et
tu les files aux restaurateurs quand tu
veux au restaurant et tu amènes en fait
ta campagne au restaurant autant
compagnon peu importe
je sais pas combien alors là je connais
pas les je connais pas le les sanctions
tu vois tout à l'heure on parlait de
sanctions là je les connais pas mais
concrètement c'est comme si tu as fait
t'imprimer des niveaux billet de banque
donc il y a pas plus de richesses qui
sont créés mais il y a des billes en
circulation et tu vas les donner au
restaurateur en fait et contre quoi il
va te livrer ton repas du midi
mais le vrai sujet c'est là où en fait
c'est impossible de faire du timing
savoir quand est-ce que ça s'arrête
qu'est-ce qu'un billet de banque et
revenons toujours en fait à ce que sont
les choses concrètement parlant un
billet de banque c'est pas autre chose
qu'un contrat de confiance entre toi et
moi si j'ai le billet de banque et je te
le donne et bien tu as confiance dans la
valeur ce billet de banque et contre
quoi tu vas me livrer le bien ou les
services prenant l'exemple du
restaurateur le repas du midi mais
évidemment maintenant tu prends un peu
de hauteur et tu dis maintenant toi
restaurateur tu sais que tous les jours
il y a quelqu'un qui imprime des
nouveaux billets de banque et qu'il est
qu'il est donne à celui qui est à ton
client potentiel et qui est susceptible
de te donner il va se passer
le sujet d'ailleurs les notes les
agences et les agences de notation qui
font les notes mais et d'ailleurs le
bonheur est relatif oui la France est
pas plus mal que les autres puisqu'on
fait tous les mêmes conneries une
certaine manière mais au-delà de ça
finissant le raisonnement pour que les
gens comprennent bien concrètement quand
tu imprimes des et tu les donnes à
quelqu'un pour qu'ils viennent payer à
un moment donné je ne sais pas quand le
restaurateur dit se comprendra que la
valeur du billet de banque est pas trop
de choses quand un contrat de confiance
entre deux parties ben n'est pas la même
la confiance est rompue il voudra pas un
billet 1000 vaudra 2 et c'est pour ça
qu'à la fin des fins tout ça mais dans
un temps qu'on ne peut pas après définir
parce que la clé de tout ça c'est toi et
moi c'est la confiance qu'on se fait la
confiance qu'on a dans le billet de
banque qui est un jour vous ne savez pas
quand et bien lorsqu'on imprime trop de
billets par rapport à la richesse
concret et bien c'est logique de la
valeur du billet c'est la richesse créée
divisée par le nombre de billets en
circulation et donc à un moment donné ça
finit par l'hyperinflation c'est ça en
fait ce que ça veut dire quand tu me
réclames de billets et pas un pour me
livrer la même chose ça s'appelle le
prix vaut le double c'est
l'hyperinflation et l'hyperinflation
c'est ce que tu appelles l'effondrement
monétaire mais après l'histoire est
jalonnée de ce genre d'épisode c'est pas
la première fois qu'on fait de la
pression monétaire à l'époque on mettait
un peu moins d'or un peu moins d'argent
dans les pièces jusqu'à un moment où les
gens s'en rendaient compte et se
rendaient bien compte qu'au final ça
avait pas les mêmes valeurs et du jour
au lendemain boom rééquilibrage chez ma
fameuse ma position déséquilibre qui
retend vers une position d'équilibre
donc naturellement les politiques
d'impression monétaire à outrance moi je
ne dis pas qu'il ne faut jamais en faire
elle doivent servir à situation
exceptionnelle si situation
exceptionnelle réponse exceptionnelle ça
il y a pas de sujets sanitaire c'est là
où je dis un petit peu on aurait pu
pendant trois mois effectivement
utiliser ce levier là pour éviter que le
bébé partait avec l'eau du bain là pour
le coup jamais mais au bout de trois
mois on s'arrête tout de suite et le
vrai problème c'est quoi c'est quand on
a mis le doigt dedans quand on a mis le
doigt dedans c'est comme une drogue on a
mis le droit le doigt dans l'impression
monétaire ça veut dire concrètement que
tu as l'autorisation de nier toute
position déséquilibres j'ai la capacité
moi c'est presque du droit divin moi en
tant qu'individu en tant quantité de
toujours équilibrer toute position
qu'elle soit déséquilibrée ou pas et ça
c'est dangereux pourquoi parce que plus
le temps passe plus les équipes
s'accumulent et le jour où les gens
diront j'en veux pas un mais deux
milliers et bien concrètement il y aura
violemment un retour à l'équilibre et là
qui fera mal à tout le monde d'où la
question de la responsabilité on ne peut
pas utiliser ces armes là ok elles sont
satisfaisantes à court terme mais elles
peuvent être délétères à moyen long
terme 0 responsabilité pour les banques
centrales
on parle de pratiquement le prix Nobel
d'économie pour sa gestion de cette fée
marrer moi ça me fait pas mal bon
attends
divin Bruno Le Maire herbès le messager
la confiance dans Hermès
vous y croyez l'histoire de l'inflation
que ça va descendre que ça va stagner
que machin là je les vois permettez-moi
l'expression je les vois tortues de
du du du du du popotin
on travestissant la langue française
pour nous raconter que vous inquiétez
pas ça ira mieux demain et que ça va se
calmer tout va bien la réalité des
chiffres c'est pipeau on voit Bruno Le
Maire sur faire remettre à sa place
comment on fait pour gérer un
gestionnaire de communication qui a la
tête de la combinéième économie mondiale
la France c'est quoi maintenant 7e
septième Olivier de Lamarche Bruno
lomère est-ce que c'est un leader
charismatique qui mériterait d'avoir le
titre de Hermès
non mais je veux pas te parler de merde
sur ce que sur ce qu'a dit Pierre
le problème aujourd'hui c'est aussi
le poids des États dans l'économie le
poids des États dans le PIB c'est à dire
que sur je vais te répondre
indirectement
on est on est en France on est à 60% du
PIB qui sont des dépenses de l'État
d'accord et donc et en plus tu peux
rajouter à ça toutes les entreprises du
CAC 40 qui bossent avec l'État aussi
donc qui ont des contrats d'État ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire tout simplement
que l'État aujourd'hui
son argent il vient d'où
son argent il vient uniquement de la
dette puisqu'il a plus de d'argent
propre puisque les rentrées les rentrées
des des impôts c'est peanuts donc ça
veut dire quoi
total c'est pilote donc l'impôt sur le
revenu l'impôt sur les sociétés c'est
peinte en fait en réalité et donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que pour
pour
continuer à créer une illusion de
croissance pour continuer à financer ce
qu'ils ont à financer parce qu'il faut
quand même pas oublier une chose c'est
que les les
ils achètent en fait la paix
et donc pour l'acheter cette paix faut
des sous c'est sous ils viennent d'où
ils viennent de la dette non ils
viennent de la dette parce que
aujourd'hui tu peux plus lever plus
d'impôts tu es déjà saturation donc ils
viennent de la dette or le problème
c'est que pourrait mettre de la dette à
l'infini qu'est-ce qu'il faut
il faut pouvoir l'acheter cette dette
et donc pour le pour l'acheter cette
dette parce que aujourd'hui personne
n'en veut surtout quand elle se
trimbalait à zéro pour cent donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut en
face que tu que tu
imprimes des billets c'est ce que font
les Japonais aujourd'hui ils émettent de
la dette ils en sont à 7 à 10% de
déficits budgétaires par an donc et il
faut bien il faut bien l'acheter puisque
c'est eux-mêmes qui l'achètent donc
c'est le c'est la c'est la b.o.j qui
l'achète donc qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils
émettent des billets donc cette histoire
n'a pas de faim le problème c'est ça
c'est que quand tu mets le doigt dedans
et c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on disait
moi je le répétais sur tous les plateaux
en 2008 et en 2009 quand ils ont
commencé à à nous sortir cette planche à
billets j'ai dit attention c'est comme
une drogue vous mettez le doigt dedans
c'est terminé vous êtes obligé de
continuer à vie et c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait parce que tu n'avais plus de
croissance générée tu n'avais plus de
croissance organique et donc la seule
croissance qui avait c'était la
croissance qui était dû aux dépenses de
l'État et l'État est de plus en plus
gourmand parce que l'État ne va jamais
se restreindre
parce que le truc le plus facile c'est
de faire de la dette si tu si t'as pas
envie de bouffer du riz en permanence
pendant 20 ans qu'est-ce que tu fais tu
fais de la dette un prime non je
plaisante mais après tu es pour manger
mais juste un élément important parce
que c'est super d'une certaine manière
le moment est assez intéressant parce
que je sais pas si les auditeurs en fait
le savent mais ça fait un an que les
banquiers centraux essaye d'en sortir
sevrage on essaye depuis un an de ce
sevrer et là ce qui est assez
intéressant puisque les taux sont passés
de zéro à 5% grosso modo ça dépend les
endroits du monde mais de 0 à 5 % et là
c'est intéressant parce qu'on a vraiment
sous les yeux la démonstration qu'on
peut plus en sortir qu'on peut plus en
sortir sans avoir sans en passer par une
vraie un vrai reset quoi une vraie
reconstruction j'en veux pour preuve un
élément simple et ça ça va parler à tout
le monde sujet de l'immobilier avant
même de parler de la soutenabilité de la
dette un truc tout bête immobilier
immobilier il se passe quoi il se passe
que quand les taux ne ces
tout à chacun achète de l'immobilier il
l'achète pas avec l'argent sur son
compte en banque qui achète l'immobilier
c'est la banque qui achète l'immobilier
pour soi donc en gros qu'est-ce qu'on
fait qu'on veut acheter un bien
évidemment il faut avoir du désir le
besoin mais surtout le désir d'acheter
en fait le mien mais la première chose
qu'on fait c'est qu'on va voir le
banquier on va dire je peux avoir
combien mais il faut avoir en tête quand
même à quel point c'est compliqué de
pouvoir en sortir c'est que quand je me
finance à 1% pour acheter mon meilleur
immobilier sur 20 ans à mensualité
constante 1000 euros peu importe le
montant mais prenant 1000 euros
mensualité constante quand vous allez
voir votre banquier et que ça a 1% et
vous dit temps aujourd'hui avec des taux
à 4% c'est juste 3% plus 3% plus 4% aux
États-Unis c'est à 7 on est passé deux à
7 c'est 5% de plus bah 3% de plus le
banquier vous dit vous aurez droit à 25%
de moins 25% de moins il se passe quoi
il se passe qu'en fait le marché
s'arrête tout de suite et donc c'est ce
qui nous attend au second semestre et
les marchés immobiliers quel que soit
l'Android du monde c'est un excellent
exemple on a été tellement loin dans la
politique de taux zéro et d'impression
monétaire aujourd'hui c'est que dès
qu'on essaye d'en sortir tout fout le
camp et quand on dit tofu le camp pour
parce que c'est notre métier c'est mon
métier aujourd'hui vous regardez en fait
tous les indicateurs associés à ce type
de marché il y a plus de vente les
transats les volumes de transaction sont
arrêtés les prix commencent à chuter et
chuteront d'autant que les taux
continueront de monter parce que une
chose simple pour que les gens
comprennent bien quand les taux passent
de 4 à 1 et vous dit vous avez droit à
25% plus donc les prix font 25% car les
taux montent de 1 à 4 et bien les
banquiers Audi moins 25% de moins donc
il n'y a pas d'autres choix que
d'accepter le fait que les prix baissent
de 25% mais attention qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé tout le monde parle d'emploi
et de chômage mais au cours des cinq ou
si des dernières années quel est le vrai
secteur d'activité qui a fait créer de
l'emploi d'un quasi tous les pays du
monde au hasard secteur de la
construction de la rénovation ça vous
surprend mécanetto vu qu'on a manipulé
on a amené les taux à zéro et bien c'est
comme si on donnait plus d'argent à tout
le monde pour stimuler le secteur de la
construction et l'immobilier et bien
naturellement il on a construit de plus
en plus de logements donc les gens qui
construisent les maisons les plombiers
etc ont de plus en plus de business les
carnets de commandes qui sont plein donc
rien qu'en France 400 000 emplois en
plus depuis 2017 dans le secteur de la
construction et bien j'aimerais qu'on
m'explique oui c'est comme en fait un
engrenage sur pareil vous seulez la
demande finale à travers ça et bien vous
dynamisez tout en secteur d'activité et
tout le monde en profite malheureusement
il y a deux côtés de la 2 côtés de la
montagne dès que les tomates la musique
s'arrête et c'est un peu comme le coyote
qui continue de courir vous savez
au-dessus de la falaise à un moment
donné il s'aperçoit qu'il y a le vide en
dessous et boum ça tombe et le vrai
sujet il est là second semestre de cette
année-là il faut que les gens soient
conscients de cela parce que là pour le
score c'est un peu on est un peu dans le
coyote là le coyote qui continue
d'avancer mais pour le coup nous faisons
l'expérience in situ
de l'augmentation des taux de la d'une
tentative de sortie de politique
monétaire expansionniste qu'on a
implémenté depuis 10 à 15 ans avec un
gros boost avec la crise sanitaire nous
faisons une tentative depuis un an et
bien nous verrons et là pour le coup
nous pourrons revenir pour être
comptable en fait des résultats mais le
freinage associé sera extrêmement brutal
quasi quel que soit l'endroit du monde
et aujourd'hui on a pu repousser cela je
dis juste un mot pour dire pourquoi
finalement c'est pas tout de suite
pourquoi ça n'arrive pas tout de suite
c'est parce qu'en fait l'économie c'est
pas une science comme si certaines
personnes veulent vous le faire croire
l'économie c'est pas autre chose que
l'agrégation de nos comportements nos
comportements à nous en tant que
consommateur à nous en tant
qu'entrepreneur plus l'état
économique économiste
pour donner plus de crédibilité aux
astrologues
elle est bonne mais juste pour dire
simplement pourquoi il y a des délais ça
m'étonne pas
[Rires]
tu vas prendre un bâton de berger
miniature mais tout ça pour dire
simplement que pourquoi ça met du temps
et ça met toujours du temps c'est parce
que vous êtes une entreprise votre
projet il est déjà là prenez le secteur
de la construction votre carnet de
commandes c'est pas le carnet de
commandes du jour c'est le carnet de
commande de l'année qui vient de se
passer et donc il faut bien les servir
donc vous avez besoin en fait de
beaucoup de matériaux de beaucoup de
manœuvre pour régler finalement une
problématique et c'est celle d'hier et
là ce qu'on entend en train de dire
c'est que la problématique du jour est
en train de changer du tout j'avais de
compliqué à gérer dernier point un
élément important pardon mais simplement
aux États-Unis aussi parce qu'il faut
pas qu'on soit toujours trop poteau
centré pourquoi là c'est très concret
parce qu'ils ont commencé un peu à nous
pourquoi on s'en est pas encore aperçu
véritablement du ralentissement en tout
cas pas aussi fortement qu'on pourrait
s'y attendre car les taux montent aussi
fortement pour une raison toute simple
c'est parce que avec la crise sanitaire
on a filé du pognon aux gens qu'ils
avaient déjà mis un peu de côté donc ils
avaient un pactole de côté donc quand
vous avez en fait le besoin ou l'envie
en fait de réaliser quelque chose et
bien vous avez un peu moins d'argent
tout de suite disponible mais c'est pas
grave j'ai de côté jeu prends un peu
dans mon Madeleine ça c'est ce qui
arrive dans un permettant deuxièmement
survie avec quoi on achète on achète
plus avec des billets et les pièces
maintenant on achète avec une carte tant
que la carte elle dit oui tant que la
carte elle fonctionne et bah ça marche
et ben je te pose une question l'année
dernière est-ce que tu sais comme de
combien évoluer le distribution de
crédit via carte bancaire aux États-Unis
et le taux d'intérêt carte bancaire
c'est 20 points 20 %. 20 % combien plus
15 % par rapport à l'année dernière
c'est tout simple les gens taper dans
les madeleines dans un premier temps on
fait continuer enfin on continue à
utiliser la carte de crédit qui a bien
voulu marcher jusqu'au moment où la
banque dit elle marche plus il y a un
deuxième point et là ça va ça va changer
assez rapidement
il faut se souvenir que byden pendant le
covid avait suspendu le remboursement
des prêts étudiants or ça ça pèse
énormément
et secondo ça représente il y a eu un
calcul qui a été fait ça représente par
mois ça représente 450 dollars qui n'ont
pas été payés
donc ça veut dire plus de 5000 dollars
sur l'année et ça ça a apporté
évidemment puisqu'il y avait plus cette
dépense là ça a apporté un délai
supplémentaire maintenant qui vont être
que les remboursements vont reprendre ça
veut dire que tu en [__] 450 dollars
par mois de de
pouvoir d'achat et ça ça veut dire que
les ventes au détail vont plonger aux
États-Unis et que ça peut faire très mal
en plus dernier point le point qui n'est
pas que l'immobilier je rappelle que
aujourd'hui dans les banques vous avez
des portefeuilles obligataires qui sont
importants ces portefeuilles
obligataires ont été achetés aussi avec
des taux à 0%. quand une obligation est
achetée avec un taux à 0% et qu'elle
monte à 5% et ben ça veut dire que tout
simplement ton actif c'est à dire le
prix de l'obligation à diminuer de 40 à
50%. ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui est une le vois pas tu ne
le vois pas pourquoi parce que
comptablement tu le tues la comptabilise
au modèle et non au marché mais quand tu
as des gens qui commencent à sortir soit
parce qu'ils ont besoin de leur épargne
soit parce que
il panique c'est ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs et c'est ce qui a été
interrompu très vite par les banques
centrales qu'il voyait d'un très mauvais
œil c'est-à-dire la fuite des capitaux
des banques régionales alors évidemment
elles sont parties des banques
régionales mais elles sont allées dans
des grandes banques américaines donc
mais c'est pas un solde complètement nul
parce que la banque régionale desquelles
la fuite décapiteaux arrive elle est
obligée de vendre sur le marché et quand
elles vont sur le marché elle vend à 50%
de baisse elles vont pas au prix du
modèle donc ça veut dire que tu te
retrouves avec des pertes monumentales
et que tu as en plus sur ces obligations
la plupart du temps des dérivés
d'obligation et que là aussi ça fait
très mal et donc tu es aujourd'hui dans
une situation où on sait très bien que
si on continue à garder des taux à 5%,
ça veut dire que les obliques en fait
dans les banques dans les assurances vie
elles sont en réalité à 50% de baisse si
jamais il y a des centrés la panique si
jamais il y a des sorties
tu as si jamais tu as un bon creux or il
semble quand tu regardes les graphiques
que il y a de moins en moins de dépôts
en banque depuis le début de l'année ça
veut dire que de l'argent sort des
banques françaises pour aller
les gens épargne moi ou les gens ou les
gens épargnent moins ce qui est aussi
mais tu as une chute tu as une chute
assez brutale donc ça veut dire que
probablement les gens épargnent moins ça
c'est une certitude mais que tu as aussi
des sorties et que ces sorties là si
elles ne rentrent pas dans une autre
banque si elles vont suivre si elles
vont ailleurs se mettre ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que les banques vont
être obligées de vendre leur une en
partie leur portefeuille obligataire et
donc de constater les pertes et là ça
risque de faire très mal
j'ai une question à vous poser
concernant la capacité qu'à notre état
notre ministre de l'économie à faire oui
il commence sérieusement me sortir par
les yeux parce que là il faut arrêter un
peu là c'est la fin de l'année comment
ça me fatiguer quand j'entends Emmanuel
Macron dire que qui aurait pu prévoir
les émeutes là ça commence
à piquer un peu il commence à m'énerver
un peu donc pour en revenir à ton
ministre de l'Économie
est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils sont mal
renseignés est-ce qu'ils font de la
gestion de crise façon ne paniquez pas
vous inquiétez pas il y a un pilote dans
l'avion parce que quand on l'entend
s'exprimer sur les prévisions de
l'inflation les prévisions de croissance
les prévisions quoi que ce soit on a
l'impression de voir soit un grand
mythomane
soit quelqu'un qui ne sait pas où il est
beau il habite il sait plus où il habite
où il fait de la gestion de crise en
mode ne paniquez pas tout va bien la
France ça va les émeutes ça craint rien
comme problème les investisseurs ils ont
pas peur du tout donc est-ce que vous
jugez les capacités de renseignement
d'interception d'information de du
ministère des Finances et de Bercy à la
juste hauteur de l'air qu'on traverse où
ils sont en mode panique on fait de la
politique symptomatique on gère la
panique comme il faut le temps qu'il
faut au jour le jour sans mode où est-ce
que c'est des bâtiments
si jamais les gens sortent s'il est
jamais il déclenche un mouvement de paix
c'est-à-dire que attention ça arrivera
pas parce que la banque centrale se met
en face direct
aux États-Unis
en l'espace d'une semaine bien sûr allez
au bout d'une semaine ils ont calmé les
choses on est d'accord le seul truc
c'est que il va pas te dire Bruno Le
Maire va pas te dire en te regardant
dans les yeux oui on est tellement dans
la merde que on va jamais s'en sortir
donc évidemment c'est c'est des
communicants mettez-vous ça dans la tête
c'est pas des gérants c'est pas des
c'est pas des créatifs c'est des
communiquants donc quand même être
obligé de communiquer pour justifier
leur choix
non non parce que ils se disent qu'il y
aura jamais aucune conséquence donc il
communique et continueront à communiquer
et ils te diront tel le coq qui chante
les pieds dans la dans la dans le fumier
et bien il continue de chanter les pieds
dans le seinque voilà Bruno Le Maire
c'est un coffre ne dégrade pas s'il te
plaît l'emblème national bon donc
arrière plusieurs points sur l'aspect
obligataire etc bankroll moi j'y crois
pas vraiment pourquoi
personne ne l'a dit mais là la banque
centrale américaine avait mis 12 mois à
diminuer son bilan de 650 milliards elle
a mis une semaine de le remonter pour le
remonter de 440 donc tu vois que quand
il faut ils y vont et ils y vont parce
que toute façon il pense qu'il y a
aucune conséquence donc ils vont ils
iront toujours donc ils répondront comme
ça donc c'est pas c'est moins mon sujet
par exemple je reviens sur la notion de
l'immobilier immobilier c'est plus
dangereux que l'obligataire pour une
raison toute simple c'est parce que pour
le coup une banque là les fonds
obligataires c'est tellement gros que
les banquiers centraux et les étapes
peuvent pas les laisser tomber c'est
toubib too face c'est comme ça c'est pas
très bon parce que ça pousse pas la
responsabilité et la responsabilisation
puis ça veut dire que je n'ai plus à
subir les conséquences de mes actes
c'est ça le concept c'est si j'agis mal
c'est pas grave je serai toujours sauvé
ça pousse pas en fait avoir des
comportements exemplaires ça c'est vrai
oui oui mais si c'est longtemps après
bah après moi le déluge donc d'une
certaine manière c'est on peut en
trouver plein des comme ça mais juste
pour avoir en tête le concept de
l'immobilier c'est très différent un
fond de l'oublier c'est pas très grave
il y a plein de producteurs comme cela
et aux États-Unis qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé la face au fait que les gens ont
acheté de l'immobilier qui était très
très cher quand vous achetez de
l'immobilier vous achetez un bail
commercial là j'en parle encore la
semaine dernière avec des acteurs du
sujet commercial c'est quoi c'est pas
juste des gens qui payent un loyer il
faut qu'ils aient les moyens de payer un
loyer et quand vous êtes face en fait au
ralentissement économique face à des
commerçants qui au-delà même des crises
au quotidien en fait on de plus en plus
de mal à faire face à leurs charges et
ils se passent quand il y a de plus en
plus de défauts en fait de loyer et donc
vous êtes face à un situation où les
gens ont acheté quoi ont acheté la
sécurité du patrimoine n'oublions pas ça
comment c'est vendu l'immobilier c'est
quoi c'est l'équivalent d'une obligation
l'immobilier c'est du tangible il y a
pas de risque donc non ça dépend
dis-le-moi je te le dirai si je le sens
commence à couler dans les rues
il est temps d'investir dans la pierre
on en est pas encore là mais après même
si je pourrais vous raconter d'autres
choses on peut investir dans la pierre
autrement voilà dans les petits villages
dans des maisons abandonnées etc il y a
plein de manières de faire l'ingéniosité
elle permet de faire plein de choses
mais pas comme tout le monde et pour
gagner de l'argent comme ça de manière
gratuite ça ça existe pas ou rarement
mais simplement pour vous dire que dans
l'immobilier il se passe qu'il y a des
gens qui ont acheté ça pour la sécurité
une blinde après après une blinde qui en
séchage une blinde et aujourd'hui ils se
font face à des niveaux de valorisation
qui sont hyper élevés face à des
locataires qui peuvent plus payer en
l'occurrence pour l'instant il a raison
il y a pas de prix le prix c'est pas le
prix de la transaction c'est le prix
fabriqué sur un coin de table par des
évaluateurs pas sur un coin de table je
caricature mais c'est fait donc on n'est
pas obligé de faire la vérité du prix
tout de suite mais si jamais si jamais
les taux restent à ces niveaux là
pendant plus d'un an et que le
ralentissement économique tel qu'on le
prévoit mais là c'est même pas une vue
de l'esprit c'est pas être positif ou
négatif c'est juste on l'a choisi c'est
nous qui appuyons les deux prêts sur les
deux pieds sur le frein donc c'est
logique et bien si ça dure plus d'un an
il va falloir faire la vérité sur les
prix et essayer d'en finance le plus
dangereux c'est quoi c'est pas de
prendre une grosse pomme car les gens
savent ce qu'ils ont acheté et qu'ils
ont bien compris les risques associés
c'est pas un problème de perdre de
l'argent c'est en jeu par contre le plus
grave c'est quoi et je rappelle j'en
reviens à 2007 le déclenchement de la
vraie crise financière à l'époque c'est
quoi c'est un fond monétaire d'une
grande banque française font monétaire
il était ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire
grosso modo je mets mon argent là au
lieu de me faire du 3% c'est le sans
risque de l'époque ça va me faire du 3,3
ça me va très bien et bien ce fond là il
fait quoi il fait moins un ou moins 2 à
l'époque je me souviens plus moins en
moins de juste moins en moins de c'est
pas très grave mais c'est terrible
pourquoi parce que quand tu as fait une
promesse à quelqu'un et tu lui as vendu
cette chose là comme la sécurité et
qu'il s'aperçoit que tu es très loin de
la promesse que tu as réalisé et bien en
l'occurrence qu'est-ce qui se passe et
bien les gens ils disent toujours la
même chose plus jamais ça et le danger
dans notre monde financier c'est quand
les gens se disent s'aperçoivent qu'ils
ont acheté quelque chose qui ne
correspond pas à leurs attentes et à
partir de la 10 plus jamais ça et
partent en même temps et là c'est le
bordel et là pour rattraper en fait le
bébé qui paraît que du bain là c'est
compliqué les banquiers centraux doivent
donc tout ça pour dire que le sujet des
banques pour moi c'est notre ligne
Maginot on a eu tellement mal à
2008-2009 qu'on fera tout pour les
sauver mais comme à l'époque pose 14-18
on a fait la ligne Maginot à imagineuse
c'était quoi c'est plus jamais ça mais
sauf que 15 ans plus tard et bien ils
sont passés à côté et le vrai sujet
c'est tout le reste c'est les fonds de
probabilités c'est-à-dire comment on a
fléché hors des banques beaucoup de
financement pour financer des startups
puis début des sociétés qui sont plus
grosses que des startups à des niveaux
de l'aération qui sont dément comment
pareil on a fait chier beaucoup dans
l'immobilier tout ça ce sont des
activités non réguler c'est pas qu'ils
font c'est il faut rien de entre
guillemets d'illégal hein c'est pas
régulé simplement on est à amené
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent donc c'est
moi le sujet des banques qui est pour
nous et à peu près notre inimagino que
en fait tout l'argent qu'on a fait
passer ailleurs ou par ailleurs à côté
finalement des banques et qui circulent
aujourd'hui et qui peut-être à risque et
peut nous amener en fait à des
situations un peu difficiles à gérer
tu veux rajouter un mot ou sinon je te
pose une question Internet
une question qui t'énerve
tu sais il y a plus grand chose qui
m'énerve effondrement de la monnaie d'où
l'importance du Bitcoin Olivier
il va s'énerver ça me fatigue non c'est
je m'énerve pas ça me fatigue ça me
fatigue c'est à dire que
quand tu vois Black Rock quand tu vois
les banques centrales commencer à dire
oui c'est quand même bien les monnaies
numériques c'est bien ce que je dis
depuis des années genre j'avais compris
enfin c'est ça me paraît
les États qui sont aujourd'hui en train
de te préparer des monnaies numériques
pourquoi pour avoir la main sur toi
des monnaies qui seront en réalité
programme qui t'obligeront à les
dépenser qui t'obligeront qui froncent
en sorte de valeurs que tu ne puisses
pas l'épargner et si tu ne peux pas
l'épargner et ben tu ne peux pas être
propriétaire de quoi que ce soit donc ça
veut dire que tu seras locataire de tout
donc la fameuse phrase de Cloud choix
qui dit vous ne serez propriétaire de
rien vous serez locataire de tout et
vous serez heureux bon ben voilà c'est
on y arrive et on y arrive comme ça par
ce biais de de l'euro numérique et des
et des autres monnaies numériques il a
renoncé à toutes ses propriétés
très au dessus de ça donc
le le l'implémentation de la monnaie
numérique c'est dans les tuyaux et et je
pense qu'au temps dans certains pays ça
sera compliqué parce qu'il y a certains
pays comme l'Allemagne comme la Suisse
comme les Pays-Bas etc qui sont très
attachés au liquide qui veulent aussi
supprimer et bien
autant je pense qu'en France ça passera
comme une lettre à la poste parce que
tout le monde trouve ça très pratique et
que la vie est belle en payant avec sa
carte ou même avec son téléphone j'en ai
vu un dans le train ce matin et il n'y
avait pas de réseau c'est ballot bon tu
fais comment et bah le gars il a attendu
il a poire ôté pendant 25 minutes pour
payer son café à 1 euro parce qu'il
avait pas le moindre COPEX sur lui il
avait même pas de carte il avait juste
son téléphone donc pour moi c'est
surréalisme enfin c'est comme ça et donc
les états veulent aller vers ça et tu
crois que les États ils vont accepter
d'avoir des concurrents
un concurrent sur lequel tu peux aller
t'échapper entre guillemets
et donc bien sûr que non donc et je le
dis depuis le début le Bitcoin n'est pas
anonyme que je sache donc ça veut dire
que c'est très simple tu pénalises la
transaction du Bitcoin tu pénalises la
transaction de Bitcoin à partir de ce
moment-là ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que tu payes quelque chose en Bitcoin
prison
bien là je vais te dire ton Bitcoin il
vous pleurer
alors tu auras d'autres d'autres choses
en crypto qui marcheront qui marcheront
parce que ça répondra à un besoin et et
exactement comme la bulle enfin la bulle
Internet de 2000 il y a des choses qui
ont marché il y a des choses qui ont
fonctionné et qui ont eu un bel avenir
il y a des choses
99% qui sont plantés et ben là c'est
exactement la même chose sauf que il y a
des gens qui n'ont jamais rien connu
avant et qui se sont engouffrés la dent
disant ça y est on a trouvé l'alpha et
l'oméga non vous n'avez pas trouvé
l'alpha et l'oméga c'était
malheureusement pour vous j'ai une
mauvaise nouvelle vous aurez alors en
attendant ça peut monter ça peut baisser
vous pouvez faire du trade dessus j'ai
aucun souci avec ça mais vous êtes allés
sur la plupart sont allés sur le Bitcoin
pourquoi ils sont allés sur le Bitcoin
pour échapper aux monnaies Fiat pour
échapper à cette monnaie qui est
manipulée par les États et ils vont sur
quoi une monnaie qui est manipulée par
des baleines par des gros des musk qui
en profitent et pourquoi ils en
profitent ces gens-là mais tout
simplement parce que ils ne sont pas
répréhensibles vu que ça n'est pas
régulé à partir de ce moment-là ils
peuvent manipuler autant qu'ils veulent
les crypto en se faisant un fric de fou
alors qu'il y a des gamins qui vont se
planter dessus joyeusement avec de
l'effet de levier d'accord et en se
disant bah si Elon Musk qui va c'est que
ça doit être génial ou si le patron de
BlackRock il va ça doit être super mais
non le problème c'est qu'il vous
manipule et c'est eux gagnent de
l'argent énormément d'argent avec
zéro risque parce que je rappelle un
tout petit peu pour ceux qui ont la
mémoire courte Elon Musk a manipulé son
titre Tesla par des Twitter
à manipuler son titre Tesla il a été
condamné pour d'accord il a évité
simplement l'interdiction à vie de gérer
une entreprise en payant 25 millions de
dollars à la secte d'accord c'est c'est
une propriété en Floride voilà 25
millions de dollars à la SEC il a évité
petite propriété voilà il a évité
l'interdiction à vie de gérer une
entreprise mais et là il a il a été
attrapé pourquoi parce qu'il avait
manipulé un titre qui était réglementé
sans s'en rendre compte après il a
manipulé d'autres cheat coins
Shiba et compagnie tout ça comment tout
simplement tout simplement parce que
il n'a aucun risque il peut le manipuler
ouvertement sans finir en prison
à savoir que une soyez convaincu d'une
chose une monnaie c'est un attribut du
politique toujours donc pendant un temps
donc
d'accord
le royaume de France a étouffé lui duché
à travers son pouvoir de battre monnaie
en fait il y a deux attributs du
politique qui font la légitimité du
politique et c'est toujours comme ça
qu'on aime qu'on n'aime pas c'est même
pas un choix c'est le pouvoir législatif
et le pouvoir de battre Monet point
barre tout le reste ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que ce genre de choses c'est
un actif qui peut monter ou faire faire
gagner énormément d'argent mais c'est un
actif à utiliser comme une action ou une
obligation ou une immobilier ce n'est
pas une monnaie le problème dans la
crypto-monnaie c'est son nom ça ne
devrait pas s'appliquer crypto monnaie
question pour de olivier de la Marche
bonjour pouvez-vous demander à Monsieur
de la marche pourquoi il n'évoque pas
les IRS interest right swap quand il
parle des achats de dettes
gouvernementale à des prix
historiquesment plus hauts que ceux du
marché actuel en effet les IRS protègent
les détenteurs de la dette en
transformant son taux fixe en taux
variable comme ce dernier est aussi
réévalué au prix du marché si on perd
100 sur un titre on gagne 100 sur l'IRS
plus l'évaluation de la jambe flottante
de l'IRS
de choses d'accord donc juju tu viens de
te faire bâcher tu rentres chez toi tu
te tais question qui n'est pas
d'internet on arrive à la fin de nos
deux heures 19 d'interview est-ce que
vous voulez traiter d'un sujet qu'on n'a
pas évoqué alors il y en a tellement
alors je tiens à préciser pour ceux qui
nous suivent après deux heures 19
d'interview que notre entrée
s'effectuera beaucoup plus tôt que prévu
et que nous allons parler économie avec
de lourd donc je vous réserve la
surprise eux ils sont au courant donc
est-ce que vous avez un sujet à lancer
tout de suite maintenant une question un
questionnement ou un quelque chose que
vous voulez aborder avec notre
communauté quelque chose qui est très
important pour vous comme pour eux
non si ce n'est que enfin si il m'a dit
personnel on a parlé en fait on a fait
des diagnostics j'avoue ça fait
longtemps que je fais ce métier j'ai
créé en fait une structure dont c'est le
métier qu'il fait de manière
relativement rigoureuse en tout cas je
l'espère mais j'en ai un peu marre en
fait qu'on parle toujours du diagnostic
et la question fondamentale c'est on
parle de construction c'est pas les
solutions les solutions même le mot gène
à savoir le dire c'est quoi les
solutions c'est comme si en fait il y
avait des modèles qui marchaient un
endroit qu'il fallait aller capter pour
pouvoir les refaire chez nous non le
vrai sujet c'est qu'il mon sens c'est
qu'il faut vraiment se mettre dans une
situation comme j'ai oublié tout à
l'heure de reconstruction et puis après
derrière redéfinir quelles sont ses
fondations moi les fondations c'est quoi
c'est le bottomeux c'est le territoire
c'est comprendre les gens et ça veut
dire quoi c'était au plus près d'eux ça
veut dire qu'il faut faire d'une
priorité nationale un truc tout simple
la lutte contre l'anonymat tout à
l'heure j'ai commencé par cela en disant
et en expliquant l'expliquant évidemment
peu importe un humain surtout non mais
je vais vous donner un exemple un
exemple à quel point c'est important de
se connaître et se reconnaître
d'ailleurs quand on parle en fait de
nouvelles aspirations des populations
quand tu croises les gens dans la rue
quand tu les emplois quand tu veux les
employés aujourd'hui même les nouveaux
collaborateurs qu'est-ce qu'ils le
réclament qu'est-ce qu'il réclame
souvent
non erican pas d'argent ça c'est de la
confiance il reste non il réclame
souvent du sens et le sens ça saute en
quoi mais on va y passer juste quelques
instants parce que à mon sens si tu veux
te reconstruire il faut en fait mettre
les choses dans l'ordre mettre l'église
au milieu du village puis dans un
village dans lequel l'église est au
centre c'est pas très dur le sens
comment la porte ça soute en quoi le
sens le sens ça sous-tend d'abord avoir
une vision du monde qui vient avoir une
vision du monde qui vient et avoir
assumé la place qu'on veut occuper dans
le monde qui vient assumer la place
qu'on veut occuper dans le monde qui
vient c'est vrai à l'échelle d'une
entreprise aujourd'hui si tu veux
attirer en fait les jeunes
collaborateurs il ne suffit pas de les
payer ce sera pas suffisant et même les
gens que tu payes aujourd'hui en fait
ils partiront pour un autre tu dois
absolument si tu veux reconstruire et
aligner toutes les énergies vers le même
point avoir défini la place que tu veux
occuper dans le monde qui vient je pose
la question aujourd'hui est-ce que ici
dans cette salle vous êtes en capacité
de me dire et de comprendre et de
formuler la place qu'on veut occuper
dans le monde qui vient en tant que
société française
j'ai
quelques petites idées mais aujourd'hui
en fait c'est pas formulé comment
veux-tu donner du sens sans intellectuel
et sans en termes de direction si t'as
pas de perspective donc c'est déjà en
fait la première pierre ça c'est le
premier point 1 assume c'est ça une
gouvernance c'est ça le pouvoir c'est le
pouvoir dans un pays c'est le pouvoir
aussi dans une entreprise le pouvoir
dans une entreprise c'est quoi c'est
avoir le pouvoir de définir la place
qu'on veut occuper dans le monde qui
vient et ensuite derrière faire adhérer
les gens pour qu'ils justement puisse
tendre vers ce point là ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point on fait
en termes méthodologique pour nous et ça
on y tient énormément une fois que vous
avez dit ça vous avez pas dit grand
chose je dis vraiment en fait l'objectif
après c'est les moyens c'est comment on
y va et le comment on y va ça sous-tend
un élément et un mot hyper important la
confiance tu l'évoquais tout à l'heure
la confiance quant à la capacité des
gens à choisir le chemin qu'il veut
l'emprunter pour réaliser l'objectif on
s'en fout qu'il prenne à droite ou à
gauche quand tank évidemment au
préalable on s'est mis d'accord sur
l'objectif et c'est pour ça que je tiens
ça peut paraître un petit peu théorique
mais définir la place quand vous occuper
dans le monde qui vient c'est un élément
nécessaire pour justement [__] la paix
aux gens que ça soit les comme une ou
les collaborateurs d'entreprise pour
dessiner et choisir le chemin qui
veulent emprunter pour y aller ça c'est
le deuxième point ça s'appelle la
subarité donc la liberté être libertaire
dans le chemin qu'on laisse emprunter à
nos concitoyens ou nos collaborateurs
pour réaliser l'objectif qu'on s'est
collectivement fixé ça c'est un élément
majeur évidemment la confiance elle suit
pas le contrôle mais d'un point de vue
méthodologie c'est important d'avoir un
test là mais c'est une vraie
reconstruction c'est une vraie
révolution on nous a pas pris à
gouverner comme ça gouverner un pays
gouverner une entreprise comme cela
c'est vraiment définir qui doit faire
quoi et donc c'est à ce prix là qu'on
peut se reconstruire et un dernier
conseil et ça c'est un élément important
dans le chemin l'arche parle aussi aux
entrepreneurs plus qu'au gouvernants ne
tombons pas dans le panneau
de
mon collaborateur veut ou mon équipe
veut passer à droite je sais qu'il faut
passer à gauche ne les forcez pas passer
à gauche laissez-les passer à droite
parce que si vous leur dites passer à
gauche une fois puis ensuite deux fois
vous devenez les chevaux et eux la
calèche et donc vous serez en situation
éternellement d'avoir à tirer tout le
monde vers l'objectif que vous êtes fixé
dans le monde dans lequel on vit aussi
complexe soit-il dans un monde à dans
lequel la richesse crise sera forcément
moins importante que par le passé
imaginez avoir le manque d'humilité qui
consisterait à dire j'ai suffisamment
d'énergie pour tirer tout le monde vers
l'objectif à mon sens ça c'est une
utopie et donc c'est la question la
question fondamentale c'est comment
faire pour que ce soit les gens et
comment accompagnez-vous en tant que
gouvernance qu'elle soit entrepreneur ou
même pouvoir comment être là pour les
aider à révéler leur potentiel comment
les aider à choisir le chemin à
emprunter ce chemin-là et surtout vous
assurer qu'on tente vers l'objectif
final ça paraît un petit peu théorique
mais philosophiquement il faut vraiment
qu'on sent que ça dans la tête j'ai la
chance de rencontrer des dizaine de
milliers de patrons par an j'interviens
beaucoup en conférence et je ne cesse de
dire que nous n'avons pas d'autre choix
qu'assumer et que relever de ce
challenge là sinon de toute façon alors
ça sera pas la mort de notre société
avec un grand S mais ça sera la mort de
nos sociétés avec un petit test parce
que nous ne serons plus attractifs pour
personne pour être attractif il faut
assumer la place qu'on veut occuper dans
le monde qui vient et foutent la paix
aux gens pour pouvoir dessiner le chemin
vers lequel on va éteindre est-ce que tu
veux pas te présenter aux élections
présidentielles
je peux te donner le numéro de ma femme
je suis pas sûr qu'elle apprécie
non non mais alors quand je vous dis ça
l'élément concret là je parlais de boîte
je parle de petite commune c'est ce que
c'est la réalité du quotidien du petites
commune de 450 habitants enfin font de
l'Auvergne vous savez ce qui tue ces
communes c'est un le manque de confiance
déjà un déjà le manque d'objectif c'est
quoi le projet commun personne ne dit
donc c'est quoi c'est vivre au quotidien
c'est régler les problèmes les uns après
les autres ça c'est un projet ça ça vous
donne envie de vous investir ça vous
donne envie en fait d'y passer du temps
parce que je vous assure en fait vous
n'êtes pas payé quand vous êtes conseil
municipal d'un petit village et il y en
a des dizaines de milliers de personnes
en fait voilà mais des centaines de
milliers des bénévoles en fait qui
agissent comme ça donc un il n'y a pas
de sens deux il y a pas de confiance et
trois il y a un truc qui tue toute prise
initiative c'est quoi c'est l'inflation
de normes on a pas le temps de parler
d'inflation ce que je n'avais un avis
assez tranché sur le sujet un peu
dissonant par rapport à la place la
seule inflation
que je considère comme acquise et c'est
malheureux c'est l'inflation de normes
et j'avais injustement un échange avec
une des représentantes au niveau
national donc tout récemment sur le
sujet pour leur expliquer en fait à quel
point c'était difficile de gérer une
petite commune sans moyens pour une
raison toute simple c'est que lorsqu'on
empile les normes qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est une primo gros au détriment du
petit le petit n'est jamais en fait un
poids sauf si on le transforme en poids
et l'inflation de normes à travers le
fait à travers son incapacité mais
matérielle humaine en termes de temps de
travail pour pouvoir assurer
c'est-à-dire que vous n'avez pas
commencé à faire votre job alors qu'il
faut répondre à toutes les membres c'est
ça en fait qui tue toute préinitiative
et je vous assure les gens font rarement
de mandats
olivier Delamarche est-ce qu'il y a un
sujet que vous que tu souhaites aborder
qu'on n'a pas abordé est-ce que tu veux
aborder quelque chose quand on va on va
aborder parce que ça fait les vacances
c'est et là vient
pierre vient de les pleurer c'est
l'histoire de l'inflation je pense que
tu avais envie qu'on en parle
j'ai envie qu'on parle de la capacité de
l'État à se renseigner à s'informer à
anticiper à prédire quand je vois notre
leader charismatique et Emmanuel Macron
ne pas anticiper le réchauffement
climatique qui aurait pu prévoir les
émeutes qui auraient pu prévoir ainsi de
suite je me dis soit ces gens sont
mauvais et médiocre soit il se foutent
de notre gueule soit ils sont
incompétents
dans quelle catégorie tu les places dans
les trois dans les trois en même temps
donc concernant l'inflation
on voit on voit Bruno lomère qui qui est
un peu le monsieur de loyal de la
confiance française et à essayer de
tenir la
confiance internationale sur la France
il le fait très bien comme il peut avec
tout un tas d'artifices tu voulais
parler d'inflation l'inflation de la
bêtise
[Musique]
j'ai peur qu'elle revienne pas en
arrière en revanche bon il y a
comme tout à chacun peut le constater
c'est ça qui est ce qui est fou
tu as pris ta voiture récemment
tu sais tu sais à combien est le pétrole
le pétrole est redescendu à 70
il faut bien enflouer les pièces de
litres
mais le problème c'est ça le pétrole est
redescendu à 70 et
à 70 le baril il
descendra très très probablement encore
en dessous pourquoi tout simplement
parce que tu es en récession quand tu es
en récession il y a moins de demandes et
quand il y a moins de demandes
les matières premières en train de se
faire tondre mais oui on est en train de
se faire tondre c'est ça que c'est ça
qu'il faut
il vous parle en permanence de de
l'inflation le problème c'est pas c'est
pas l'inflation sur les sur les matières
premières matières premières elles ont
toutes plus ou moins rebaissées le
problème c'est c'est par exemple qu'on
ne veut pas sortir du marché européen de
l'électricité ce qui fait qu'on paye
notre électricité
trois fois le prix qu'on devrait la
payer qu'on avait l'électricité la plus
décarbonée et la plus la moins chère
d'Europe sauf que comme on est soumis
aux Allemands et bien on a arrêté les
centrales nucléaires notre grand leader
alors maintenant charismatique notre
grand leader charismatique veut essayer
de recourir c'est à dire en fait ils
sont toujours en réaction ils sont
jamais en prévision ils sont jamais et
donc là tout d'un coup on lui dit bah
non c'est pas une bonne idée de
d'arrêter les centrales nucléaires alors
il t'annonce qu'il va construire 14 14
pa le problème c'est qu'on ne peut plus
les construire pour la bonne et simple
raison qu'on a plus les ingénieurs les
ingénieurs ils se sont barrés parce
qu'on leur a expliqué que toute façon la
filière elle est fermée donc évidemment
ils se sont barrés ils sont allés
ailleurs donc aujourd'hui on les a plus
on est incapable de construire les 14
EPR comme ça les 14 tu les auras
peut-être et encore je suis pas sûr dans
15 ans donc dans 15 ans le problème on
va pas on va pas se trimballer avec de
l'électricité à trois fois le prix
pendant 15 ans donc il y a un moment où
c'est très simple l'Espagne l'a fait
l'Espagne l'a fait instantanément ils
ont ils ont divisé par 3 leur note
d'électricité et le Portugal avec donc
c'est simple on sent on sait comment on
doit faire le petit problème là-dedans
c'est que c'est toujours une histoire de
de en fait de d'égo c'est à dire que on
a tellement on nous a tellement expliqué
pendant des années que l'Europe nous
protégeait que l'Europe c'était la paix
que l'Europe on voit bien d'ailleurs que
l'Europe
c'était c'était la croissance que
l'Europe c'était plus de chômage etc
qu'aujourd'hui si la France tout d'un
coup faisait comme l'Espagne et le
Portugal il disait bah vous savez quoi
allez vous faire [__] aux Allemands
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
le truc c'est qu'ils sont coincés dans
leur dans leur récit dans leur narratif
qui est là depuis des années et qui ne
peuvent plus reculer parce que ils se
disent si on recule ça crée un précédent
ça crée etc et nous on est quand même le
grand leader de l'Europe avec avec
l'Allemagne
charismatique
et donc on ne peut pas est-ce que je
peux
est-ce que je peux te couper dans cet
écart de lucidité brillant
quand tu les vois
essayer de faire perdurer le ronron
quotidien de la norme de la tout va bien
se passer nous sommes et nous resterons
le camp du Bien
quand ils vont se faire rattraper par la
réalité comment ça va se passer
parce que un jour ou l'autre quand il
faut payer il faut payer comment vous le
voyez ça ils mettent tous les outils en
place pour le faire
mettre tous les outils en place pour le
faire des outils qui leur permettront de
de continuer leur petit narratif sans
avoir de de
contre-pouvoir sans avoir de médias qui
peut qui peut aller dire oui mais enfin
c'est pas comme ça tout à fait que ça se
passe puis les dernières instants de
liberté d'expression
que tu es plus en démocratie c'est pas
parce que tu vas voter tous les 5 ans et
que tu vas mettre ton petit bulletin
dans le dans le l'urne que tu es en
démocratie c'est pas ça la démocratie
démocratie c'est par exemple ce que tu
connais en Suisse alors le système est
pas parfait mais c'est
le système de votation il vote à peu
près deux fois par mois alors tu as
plusieurs échelles il y a l'échelle en
effet
du canton de la commune etc et puis tu
as l'échelle des des lois nationales
fédérales et donc c'est
système de démocratie directe et c'est
pour moi la seule démocratie qui soit
c'est pas c'est pas une démocratie ou tu
mets un bulletin dans l'urne et après tu
as un gars qui est élu et qui se croit
tout permis c'est à dire que il est
au-dessus des lois et il fait ce qu'il
veut avec un parlement qui est l'ombre
d'un parlement qui est juste une machine
à voter on leur demande de lever le
doigt il lève le doigt on réfléchit pas
enfin il y a aucune il y a aucune
discussion quand ça veut pas passer pouf
on colle à 49,3 et puis comme ça on
passe je vais dire il y a aucune il y a
aucune aujourd'hui
réelle démocratie dans ce pays quand il
y a une voie discordante on l'étend
voilà il y a aucun problème
moi j'ai une vision un peu moins noire
du sujet et je reste je t'autorise pas à
juger ça de noir au moins noir
réaliste moi réaliste non c'est pas ça
c'est une question de point de vue parce
qu'on parle du futur c'est il faut avoir
beaucoup d'humilité en fait qu'en
parlant quand on parle d'avenir parce
que rien n'est certain je te remercie en
fait de me le rappeler mais tout ça pour
dire que la réalité c'est que tu l'as
évoqué il y a un vrai problème pour le
coup organisationnel c'est en fait la
l'inutilité je suis pas en fait
complètement convaincu sur la démocratie
participative directe je sais pas le
sujet pour moi en fait c'est surtout que
notre démocratie telle qu'elle
fonctionne et surtout notre mode de
représentation sont déficients et
notamment à travers un sujet donc c'est
tu peux changer ce que tu veux le vrai
sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui à mon sens
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui ne
représente rien et elle représente rien
pour une raison relativement simple là
aussi en gros de loin tout se ressent
mais quand tu rentres en détail tu peux
comprendre je vous donne un exemple vous
allez dire c'est une obsession mais
prenez le Puy-de-Dôme puis de Dôme au
centre de l'Auvergne puis Damien
5 ou 6 circonscriptions je sais plus si
circonscription de mémoire dans 5
circonscriptions il y a clairement
Ferrand une métropole au milieu qui
mais peu importe et donc il se passe
quoi il se passe que dans le bassin de
vie en fait il dit soir et bien le
député et bien qui va être élu il ne
peut pas ne pas être connu de ses
concitoyens et donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que le week-end quand il
revient il sera forcément comptable des
actions et des prises de position qu'il
aura prises à l'Assemblée nationale et
donc vous recréez les conditions en fait
dans votre contre à l'Assemblée
nationale au-delà en fait d'une simple
chambre d'enregistrement donc tu vois tu
poses la question de est-ce que c'est
possible c'est possible si tu poses un
bon diagnostic et tu trouves des
solutions simples redessine déjà la
carte électorale pour que les
circonscriptions amènent à l'élection de
députés qui seront comptables de leur
prise de position l'Assemblée nationale
de par dans la communauté en fait qui
sont censés représenter aujourd'hui en
fait le dessin en fait qui a été fait
permet à des gens qui sont inconnus des
populations d'être élus comment veux-tu
qu'il soit comptable derrière en fait
des actions et des prises de position
qu'ils vont faire
rien du tout moi je viens en fait en
2023 bonjour expérience de pensée si
vous aviez un fils spirituel ou que vous
aviez 20 ans de moins désolé les viock
vous l'orienteriez vers
quoi pour changer les choses ou prendre
le pouvoir
je réponds tu réponds
déjà
moi déjà c'est ça serait déjà une
démarche personnelle
dire que prendre le pouvoir déjà c'est
prendre son propre pouvoir c'est se
maîtriser soi c'est pas c'est ce
maîtriser soi à savoir tout à l'heure
Olivier évoquait la base de la science
et l'esprit critique ça veut dire qu'il
faut être critique pour être critique
être contre mais c'est toujours remettre
en question pour s'assurer que ce qu'on
dit en fait ou ce que j'entends soit la
vérité donc je dois être curieux pour
pouvoir aller toujours aiguiser cette
esprit critique ça c'est vraiment une
démarche individuelle qui vous permet
toujours de vous enrichir enrichir en
fait de votre savoir votre expérience ça
c'est un élément majeur et dans la
société dans laquelle on vit il y a un
autre conseil que je pourrais
recommander pour cela puis après
derrière j'irai pour le pouvoir c'est
vraiment de réfléchir aussi à ce qu'on
cherche dans la vie est-ce qu'on cherche
à être ou est-ce qu'on cherche à avoir
et ces deux auxiliaires là sont hyper
importants dans la langue française mais
le sont aussi en fait chez
l'être humain chez l'être humain mais
choisissez entre être ou avoir on est
dans des sociétés dans lesquelles en
fait la voir ou le fait de vouloir avoir
a pris le dessus sur le fait d'être et
je pense que pour un jeune d'aujourd'hui
il faut vraiment en fait qui ne dévoile
pas ou ne se fasse pas dévoyé par cette
idée qui est devenue une valeur un peu
cardinale à mon sens qui est fausse et
pourtant Dieu sait si je vis dans ce
monde là qui est celle du fait que avoir
amen à une situation en fait de de
confort supérieur peut-être mais au cas
pas de bonheur en fait exacerber donc la
notion de notion-là sont importantes
puis après derrière surprendre le
pouvoir le dernier point investir c'est
vous alors je sais que ce soit pas
forcément d'accord dans la vie publique
du territoire du quotidien soyez ancrés
présentez-vous aux élections municipales
de votre quartier de votre village parce
qu'en réalité les gens ont fait changer
les choses non du haut vers le bas mais
du bas vers le haut si tout le monde est
investi et à ses mis d'accord sur la
ligne vers lequel on peut tendre c'est
grâce à ça en fait qu'on renverse les
montagnes c'est rarement du haut vers le
bas ou si c'est le cas c'est par la
force
Olivier
déjà
l'expression
prendre le pouvoir me gêne
pour moi celui qui fait de la politique
c'est pas pour le pouvoir c'est pour
servir
c'est un peu différent et je me méfie
des gens qui recherchent le pouvoir ça
c'est vrai voilà beaucoup donc je
conseillerais plutôt de choisir des gens
qui veulent servir l'État qui veulent
servir la France
pourquoi tu veux pas te présenter je
suis pas une question qui se pose à ce
moment au bout de deux heures et
quelques en fait d'interview c'est pas
un projet
[Rires]
tu as un raisonnement sensé
tu gères ton couple comme un bon père de
famille je vais pouvoir partir en
vacances
avec tous ces compliments c'est merdier
c'est pas des compliments mec on est un
peu en chien en France là non
mais je suis enfin honnêtement je vais
être franc si je passe autant de temps
sur la route en France à faire des
conférences devant honnêtement quelques
milliers de personnes par an alors j'ai
pas un temps infini du coup et c'est
plutôt faire des gens qui ont souvent le
pouvoir le pouvoir dans des sociétés
petitesse ou parfois dans la société
grandès c'est parce qu'en fait je suis
convaincu que on peut encore changer on
peut encore convaincre si les gens si
l'ensemble de ces personnes là en fait
prennent conscience des enjeux celui de
la reconstruction et sur le fait qu'il
faille être humble et qu'il faut surtout
être assez précis dans les méthodes
qu'on peut employer pour se reconstruire
voilà je suis c'est comme ça aujourd'hui
que j'essaye d'apporter ma pierre au
fait qu'on arrive à se reconstruire
ensemble en sachant une chose juste ça
c'est aussi un autre conseil j'ai
longtemps vécu dans le cinquième
arrondissement de Paris à côté du Jardin
des Plantes je vis aujourd'hui dans un
petit village de 450 habitants avec mon
épouse et mes trois enfants vont à
l'école du village au bout du jardin
école publique de 30 personnes de la
petite section de maternelle au CM2 dans
un lieu que beaucoup considéré comme un
lieu perdu parce que socialement
malheureusement il y a plus d'activités
il y a plus beaucoup de Jobs et donc il
y a une forme ne peut pas installer
depuis 30 ou 40 ans mais rassurez-vous
rassurez-vous nous en sommes très
heureux je rappellerai une chose qu'il
faut jamais oublier le bonheur relative
et donc le 1 le bonheur est relatif est
de peut-être que dans nos sociétés on
devrait plutôt privilégier les gens
ingénieux que les ingénieurs même si je
le suis pour par ailleurs l'un n'exclut
pas l'autre mais c'est ça qu'on
recherche et moi ce que quand je me suis
réinstallé à la campagne à maintenant
six ans j'ai trouvé finalement un motif
d'espoir énorme parce que il y a une
forme de de puissance de vie au fait que
même lorsque les gens n'ont rien en fait
ils trouvent toujours les moyens en fait
de s'en sortir et c'est pour ça que je
suis optimiste parce que je crois pas en
fait que on puisse se laisser mourir
olivier Delamarche un livre et un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
alors écoute au niveau livre
les deux derniers livres que je suis en
train de lire c'est
le manuel de pilotage puis de prévu
donc
le PTAC tu es pas dedans là donc je suis
en train je suis en train de dire ça et
donc c'est pas c'est pas un conseil que
je donne à tout le monde de lire et le
deuxième c'était le livre de d'Alexandra
et Claude
qui s'appelle
je sais même plus
je sais plus enfin le le celle qui est
qu'elle a sorti assez récemment on
connaît pas l'auteur Olivier
c'est
celle qui bossent depuis des années et
des années sur la RN messager et
généticienne oui et qui
et qui s'est fait évidemment démolir par
notre ministre de la Santé
écoute je pense j'ai un petit peu plus
confiance dans ce qu'elle raconte elle
qui bosse là dessus depuis des années
plutôt que les apprentis sorciers et
c'est très bien fait c'est très
intéressant et je pense que c'est un
petit peu plus intelligent que ce que
peut nous sortir monsieur Véran
là-dessus
pour les jeunes générations
le Conseil Olivier conseil sur les
jeunes générations je vais je vais
je vais refaire un conseil que j'avais
déjà donné ici il y a quelques années en
disant
aux enfants de d'avoir l'esprit critique
et et
ce qui veut pas dire en effet de de
d'être absolument négatif surtout mais
surtout
douter et et
travailler les sujets
avant de l'ouvrir ce qui malheureusement
aujourd'hui n'est plus le cas pour
beaucoup de personnes pierre Savatier un
livre et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations alors allez alors c'est pas
ce que je lis en ce moment est-ce que je
relis souvent en fait c'est tout ce que
il
issu de Platon
Platon le mais non par exemple parce que
je trouve assez fascinant et c'est une
belle illustration de du monde dans
lequel on vit je trouve c'est que
l'esprit humain est un esprit
extrêmement élevé ça fait longtemps
qu'il l'est donc c'est d'une manière
déjà de nous apprendre l'humilité par
rapport à nos populations et nos
générations aujourd'hui comme si en fait
nous avons tout inventé la réalité c'est
que lorsqu'on lit ce type de d'ouvrage
Socrate en fait et les échanges et les
dialogues de Socrate c'est c'est
absolument formidable parce que tout est
moderne tout nous raconte en fait
l'époque actuelle et j'adore un mythe
notamment le mythe du tonneau percé et
c'est aussi pour ça que je recommande ce
type de lecture c'est par celui du taux
d'opercer il est tellement dans le être
le avoir que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
il est tellement l'illustration ouais
émilie est tellement l'illustration en
fait de ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui on
passe notre vie à faire croire aux gens
que le bonheur c'est l'acumuler
l'accumulation d'expérience c'est comme
essayer de remplir un tonneau percé elle
ne sera jamais assez suffisante et donc
d'une certaine manière c'est lecture là
elle vous permet de sortir de la société
de la dureté de la société aujourd'hui
de la dureté de l'information au
quotidien et en fait nous faire prendre
eSport en disant que c'était il y a déjà
2000 ans voilà donc c'est un élément
qu'il faut lire et relire parce que ce
sont des fondations sur laquelle on peut
rebâtir des référentiels qui
m'apparaissent sain et valable quel que
soit en fait l'épisode du temps qu'on
considère
messieurs merci
[Musique]